bioshock is a fantastic series and it's due to
how much these games affected me that i wanted
to talk about them all with you this video is
actually three separate parts turned into a
much larger project with each video being made
with the sole intention of not only retelling
the story of these games but to also allow me to
give my thoughts on their stories along the way
if you're new here then this is the perfect place
to watch all three videos but even if you've seen
them already there is an added section at the end
where we discuss the two novels released during
the game's life cycle with all of that out of the
way though welcome to the bioshock series story
retrospective let's get started bioshock 1 has
one of the most genius stories i have ever seen
its central plot is brilliant and the attention
to detail when it came to its setting in world
building is arguably a masterpiece just on its own
today i want to look back on bioshock's story and
uncover what really made this one of the best
games of all time despite it being 14 years
old as always spoiler warning ahead for the whole
story of bioshock and with that let's get started
as always we need to start at the prologue but
for bioshock we need to go back even further
that title bioshock it's such a bizarre word when
you think about it many games have a very distinct
title with weird meanings but at least i could
tell you what the words mean cyberpunk 2077 is
a game with a cyberpunk art style that's set in
the year 2077. a game like dragon age is a bit
tricky is i've never played dragon age before so
while its title as a whole makes no sense to me i
can at least understand what the individual words
mean dragon age and origins and maybe draw some
conclusions about the game but what is a bioshock
i like many might think it's a homage to system
shock 2 which was irrational games first project
but furthermore it could also be a shortened
version of biological shock which in the context
of the game makes sense given how ADAM ruined this
society and how our protagonist acts throughout
the game but we haven't gotten there yet so i'll
return to this in a moment as we start the game
the player needs certain questions answered in
order to feel invested in the story who are we
how did we get here and does the story make sense
bioshock creates a sort of meta narrative based
around these answers but once again more on that
at the end of the video our first interaction
with the game is a cutscene and bioshock wastes
no time getting right into the action as the plane
were traveling on crashes in the middle of the
atlantic ocean we awake amongst the wreckage and
need to find land the only place within eyesight
is a giant lighthouse next to us i've always
seen this lighthouse as a beacon of light in a
dark time although it's a bit more literal in this
case as the only light we can see is the moon the
burning plane and this lighthouse as we enter the
door shuts behind us and we see a giant statue of
a man with the phrase no gods or kings only man
written on a banner while it's confusing as is
this confusion should actually start earlier
why is there a lighthouse in the middle of
the atlantic ocean even if we were to ignore
that why isn't there people in the lighthouse
there's so much wrong with all of this and while
it does sound like a criticism i actually find it
to be a wonderful decision as it's making the
player question everything they see it's also
the start of many mysteries this game will tease
to the player which causes them to become more
invested in the world around them in an attempt
to find out more as we head down the stairs we
see three plaques with the words art industry and
science written on them while a violin cover of
bobby darin's beyond the sea accompanies us in the
bathysphere what's important to remember is why
we're going in this submarine we're in the middle
of the ocean and it's the 60s even if others had
survived that plane crash who will be going to
call for help our only option is this bathysphere
as it's either this or swimming at night in
the atlantic ocean and i'll take my chances
we presumably descend deeper into the lighthouse
while a message plays from andrew ryan someone
who looks oddly similar to the statue upstairs
bioshock has many memorable moments and this
will be one of three key moments throughout
the entire game i have rejected those answers
instead i chose something different i
chose the impossible i chose rapture
rapture might be my favorite setting in any video
game ever made not just the idea but the reasoning
behind it is brilliant the fact that a city not
only exists at the bottom of the sea but also
functions at the bottom of the sea is something
that has never been done before andrew ryan also
says that rapture was made for those who do not
fear censors or morality it's a judgment free
place but not in the sense of people getting along
and being happy together but a place that allowed
those who wanted more to get more injured ryan
says that the surface was constrained by laws and
ethics but rapture was no such place and it's
because of this ideology that allowed rapture
to blossom into what we see now a bustling city
under the sea completely shut away from society
at least that's what it seems like until we
actually enter rapture our first encounter
with the city is a very grim one as we're going
to be introduced to a man named johnny until we
get to see him sliced open right in front of us
we then meet with johnny's killer who screams
at us before attempting to open the bathysphere
it's possible that her anger is the same as the
people who used to be here as there are signs
everywhere saying things like ryan doesn't own
us let us leave and the rapture is dead earlier i
talked about a light that shines in the darkness
when i brought up the lighthouse atlas is like
the lighthouse but in a more metaphorical sense
as atlas saves us from this person who is trying
to kill us his charming demeanor and attitude
makes him instantly likable and that is further
reinforced by his own actions as once again he's
trying to save us we push further and are able to
arm ourselves with a wrench we can take a couple
practice swings to test out our new weapon but we
can also get a look at these splicers atlas was
talking about as they aren't alien creatures but
they don't look human anymore everything seems to
be going smoothly so far given the circumstances
until we see the gatherers guarded vending machine
I can't explain to
you how genuinely terrifying this was when i first
played the game currently we don't understand
what a big daddy or a little sister is just yet
so seeing a tiny child with a syringe as big
as she is walking with a moving scuba suit is
probably the most terrifying thing you'll ever see
we also discover that we can now cast electricity
through our hands which is just another bizarre
and crazy thing that rapture has we also get a
look at a concept that is shown throughout rapture
and it's how the world continues to reinforce that
you're under water it's not enough just to have
a few windows that show the sea but the effects
that the outside environment can have on rapture
such as the plane wing crashing into the tunnel
causing all the water to flood inside there are
even smaller instances of this such as the water
falling from the ceiling or just puddles of water
in places where it shouldn't be bioshock also
shows other problems that rapture can have like
a lack of electricity or when this elevator falls
and instead of just being a cool scene to ramp up
the destruction we can actually see someone walk
out of it while on fire it makes rapture seem real
as it showcases how a place like this can have
problems but also what problems a place like this
may face like water damage and poor infrastructure
if you want to go even further than this this
is also the first showcase of how the splicers
interact inside the game as this female spicer was
trying to sing a lullaby to her baby despite it
being quite the frightening tale she's talking
about how her baby is going to be sold by the
pound once her dad is gone and how she'll be alone
when her parents are both dead except it seems
like she's losing her mind as she's struggling
to figure out why her baby doesn't feel the same
anymore until we realize her baby's actually a
pistol atlas was also listening in on this lullaby
as he says that it was the plasmids that caused
all the chaos there's even an audio log not even
a couple minutes later that captures one of the
moments of rapture's downfall here's a toast to
Diane McClintock silliest girl in rapture silly
enough to fall in love with Andrew Ryan
oh god what's happening it seems that an
explosion went off during the new year's
eve party presumably right where we're standing
which killed numerous people we don't know why
but if we're to believe atlas plasmids caused it
in some way later we get to see the little sister
and big daddy again and are able to observe them
without the fear of being stabbed and it's quite
the brutal scene it shows the dynamic relationship
between the two and also the importance of the
little sister and the strength of the big daddies
we learn that the little sisters gather ADAM
while the big daddies protect them from people who
want to harm them it's also assumed that people
might want to harm the little sister because of
the ADAM that she carries after some fighting we
make it to the end of the intro where andrew ryan
appears and notices that we've invaded his city
he asks for a part of the cia or kgb as
he probably assumes that the only people
capable of finding and infiltrating his great city
would be the government and he also thinks that
the government either wants to put an end to his
city or nationalize it, two things he'll never let
happen despite being just a voice for a majority
of the game it's his personality and the power
in his voice that makes him feel like a threat
and i've always liked how impressive the voice
acting was for him of course we have to escape his
ambush and arrive at the medical pavilion endingthe tutorial
bioshock's intro is pretty much
perfect we get a cohesive set of circumstances
that show how our character made it to rapture
and then get introduced to what rapture looks
like how its inhabitants interact with the city
and a few pieces of information for the player to
think about like plasmids adam big daddies little
sisters and the downfall of rapture there is even
a ton of things we still don't know yet like who
we are who atlas is and how the plane crashed and
while i do wish more backstory was given on this
once you beat the game you realize it's impossible
to talk about right now there was so much mystery
with bioshock from its setting to its characters
to even the actual plot that it makes you want to
learn more and while this information and mystery
can be considered overwhelming when shown all at
once these mechanics characters and locations are
everywhere so it's hard not to remember them
and it also gives the player something to go
off of instead of being left in the dark all game
it's also been like 15 minutes since we started
the game so it's not like it's been four hours of
game time without any answers we're just getting
started so having a bit of mystery is perfectly
fine this early in the game and the way this
is pulled off in bioshock is expertly done from
here things start to become harder to talk about
as bioshock's main world building device is the
audio logs we find scattered around the map there
is a common critique amongst gamers that it's
unimersive when there are audio logs or recordings
scattered throughout the world as it makes no
sense that this many people would be using them
when talking about the most mundane of topics and
while i definitely agree with this sentiment i've
always just chalked it up to a limitation of game
design especially in the case of bioshock where
there are no npcs the player can talk to to learn
about rapture so all their information has to be
from the audio logs thankfully there is a ton of
them in this game and are extremely easy to find
as they glow and are more often than not found
in areas you'll be traveling through anyway these
provide lots of context to rapture's downfall and
explain a lot of what's going on around the city
except they are everywhere throughout the game and
not placed in the most linear fashion for example
we see these ghostly apparitions throughout the
game but it isn't until we get to arcadia roughly
three or so hours into the game where we finally
learn why we can see ghosts i have no problem with
the way these audio logs are structured it just
becomes a little harder to explain when making a
video about it so for now we'll just be going in
the order the game intended and occasionally go
off the beaten path to discuss some other aspects
of the game like right now as it's a perfect time
to talk about rapture itself as i said before it
wasn't just the scenery of the city that made me
love rapture but it's what it represents that
intrigued me just like the title of the game we
need to address the main name of the city rapture
by definition is a feeling of intense pleasure or
joy but it's also a theological belief within
christianity assuming my research is correct
it's an event that would be the end of times
where those who are faithful christians whether
alive or dead will be taken above the clouds to
meet the lord all those who are not faithful will
not be taken up thus are condemned to whatever
destruction the rapture brings rapture the city
relates to this as you can infer that this place
above the clouds would be considered a paradise
for all christians so rapture is a place for
those who want to experience a paradise away
from the mainland as ryan said it's for the artist
who doesn't fear censorship or the scientist who
isn't bound by a petty morality rapture allows the
creativity of the mind to be the only limit within
its walls and this is why the city of rapture had
so many scientific breakthroughs the residents of
rapture never needed to worry about whether or not
what they were doing was unethical dangerous or
controversial as they were given complete freedom
rapture essentially went through a never-ending
golden age of technological advancement people
were able to conjure elements through their
hands and were able to have not just their facial
features reconstructed but their entire gender and
even their race changed as well even though it
all went to [__] eventually just the concept
of rapture is genius it's incredibly thorough and
really highlights the stellar writing of this game
as the biggest question that comes to mind is why
build a city in the ocean and yet the devs managed
to not only give an answer to this question but
actually make it quite believable continuing where
we left off we had just escaped andrew ryan's
ambush and have made it to the medical pavilion
according to atlas this is the direction we have
to head in if we're to save his family i said
earlier how bioshock's intro showcases how some of
the splicers interact with the city and while in
that case it was just a small example this concept
gets brought up again but with more depth added to
it from the moment we enter the pavilion we
see signs and posters of a dr steinman he's
the overseer of the medical pavilion and is also a
very accomplished surgeon one thing you'll notice
about bioshock is how all the name characters have
a story about them each character has a backstory
and a reason for coming to rapture and all their
stories tie into the overarching story of rapture
each area also has a distinct look to them and a
reason for being in the city and both the levels
and characters within them all tie into rapture
in some way which we uncover from the audio logs
dr steinman performed cosmetic surgery on the
people of rapture but due to the circumstances
of the city he too became corrupt due to rapture
being a place where people can show their truest
forms and are able to push the boundaries of
their studies dr steinman would use this time
to perfect his craft everything was going well
until the discovery of adam as this sparked an
idea in steinman's head as he thought this was a
perfect opportunity to revolutionize the industry
hoping that with this new technology surgeons
could sculpt any kind of flesh with ease but this
of course led him down a darker path see steinman
was a perfectionist and of course when you're
a perfectionist your standards are incredibly
high but adam managed to push these even further
adam presents new problems for the professional
as your tools improve so do your standards
there was a time i was happy enough to take off
a wart or two or turn a real circus freak into
something you can show in the daylight but that
was then when we took what we got but with adam
the flesh becomes clay what excuse do we have not
to sculpt and sculpt and sculpt until the job is
done dr steinman didn't go crazy just because of
adam it was a combination of adam rapture and his
inability to let the smallest problem go he would
change things that patients didn't want and given
that he's a professional in his line of work he
used this to reinforce his actions why argue with
the professional after all they know all there is
to know steinman lost control and began working
on anyone he wanted even if they weren't a patient
of his his final decline is how we see him in game
he moved away from the faces of his patients to
their whole physique claiming that this one was
too fat or this one's too tall or that this one
is too symmetrical he ended up losing his mind
when he was introduced to adam he wasn't an
addict to the drug but an addict to his work
he saw the potential of adam and his first thought
was how far can he go without thinking how far
should he go this shows that adam and even the
policies of rapture affected so many of its city's
residents and due to their different fields of
study and different levels of wealth and social
status we're able to see how it affects everyone
differently this style of storytelling is flat
out genius it makes you want to go to the next
area and uncover what the level is about what it
provides the city of rapture and how its unique
setting caused its unique downfall no game has
ever gotten me to care this much about one small
level and i find that in itself very impressive
after we have dealt with dr steinman we enter the
second key moment of bioshock as we approach this
hallway we see a big daddy get thrown through the
wall this is the first time we have not only seen
a big daddy up close besides the cutscene from
earlier but we actually see one defeated so it
must be a really tough opponent who brought him
down except it's just another splicer even though
i've always found this almost impossible to happen
that's not the point of this scene as now that the
big daddy is dead the little sister is alone the
splicer takes this opportunity to grab the little
sister so he can take her at him but a mysterious
woman shoots him before he can do that i'll bring
her up in a moment but right now she and atlas
give us a choice these little sisters contain adam
the core foundation of rapture and if we can get
more we can buy more plasmids and tonics to get
stronger but we're also doing so at the cost of
potentially killing her rescuing a little sister
will net us 80 adam but she lives harvesting
her will give us 160 but she dies it's a case of
morality are you willing to sacrifice the life
of a little girl for the benefit of your own
especially when you uncover their origins it makes
the choice even more important the little sisters
were a creation of tenenbaum the woman from
earlier after discovering a sea slug that was
able to cure the wounds of a smuggler when it bit
him after some research on the slug she discovered
what caused this anomaly and dubbed the substance
adam she also discovered that had the ability to
splice people's dna giving them the opportunity
to essentially have superpowers leading to the
creation of plasmids the problem with adam is that
on its own there wasn't enough to change anything
but tenenbaum found a way to create adam inside
people's bodies but once again this also failed
as it wasn't enough the only test that worked was
with young girls which was the start of the little
sisters another problem arose is there wasn't
enough girls to go around as who would willingly
subject their daughters to this experiment so
fontaine can spread with tenenbaum to create an
orphanage that would be used as a front to exploit
the children and specifically take the girls to
use them as hosts for adam despite how creepy
they may look when you rescue them you discover
that they are just in fact little girls not some
mutant creature but a living breathing human she
with the assistance of a dr suchong who we'll
get to in a moment subjected the little girls to
mental conditioning so they can become valuable
hosts so she cares enough about the little
sisters that when someone else hurts them she'll
defend them but when she hurts them it's okay
her logic is clearly flawed and there is a reason
for that that she feels awful about what she did
but the majority of the audio logs we find say
the opposite this makes tenenbaum a hard person to
trust which not only reinforces the game's concept
of morality when it comes to the little sisters
but also strengthens the relationship between you
and atlas it's a great idea on paper but horribly
executed in game sadly according to tenenbaum
if we save enough of her little one she'll give
us a reward this is in the form of a present
near the plasmid vending machines that has atom
a plasmid and some other items like ammo and eve
the number of atom is consistent every time so if
we're to compare the two we find out that every
three little sisters rescued gives us 440 adam
assuming you collect the present and 480 if we
harvest all of them if the player were to rescue
harvest all 21 little sisters they will get either
3080 adam or 3360 adam respectively this is
already a problem on its own but they continue
to add more items for the player easily making
rescuing the best option without even thinking
about the morality of the situation a 280 adam
difference in the grand scheme of things is really
not that big of a deal especially when you get
to the end of the game when you can upgrade
your plasmids that run as high as 180 adam
now maybe i play the game differently than
others but i never needed many plasmids during my
playthrough i wasn't constantly starved of adam i
just needed a few important tonics and some go-to
plasmids and that was it you really don't need an
entire arsenal of tonics and plasmids to complete
this game unless you're doing a sort of challenge
run or something what they should have done was
kept the rewards from the present but cut the
adam we get from the gifts and rescuing in half
going from a total of 3360 adam if you harvest
them to 1680 if you choose to rescue all of them
this also cuts your survivability in half all
health and eve upgrades are 80 adam each buying
all of them throughout the game will set you back
1280 adam leaving you only 400 to use on upgrades
and plasmids so it creates the situation about
whether or not you should dabble in more health
or eve or use the adam to upgrade your plasmids
this would make saving the little sisters a lot
harder to do and force the player to actually
choose between rescuing or harvesting them
are you still willing to stick to your morals
and never harvest one no matter how hard it
gets or are you going to cave in furthermore are
you going to justify your actions or live with
the fact that what you did is wrong if you plan
on justifying it aren't you no better than the
people who live here like steinman who used his
work as justification for his ruthless actions
although loads of other people will meet soon who
also did evil things because they were furthering
their field of study i'm also not the only one
that thinks these rewards should have been handled
better as the creative director for the game even
agrees yeah and we went back and forth a lot about
what the rewards for harvesting versus saving
would be and actually i think we should have
really pushed further that the rewards for saving
were much more much more should have been much
more meager than the rewards for harvesting you
probably have noticed by now that we've spent
a lot of time talking about dr steinman and the
little sisters but not about the actual medical
pavilion itself and this is where bioshock tends
to suffer a bit the medical pavilion level has 17
audio logs the player can find and only eight
of them aren't made by dr steinman while this
sounds like a great opportunity for the other
logs to introduce more lore on the other doctors
and patients bioshock doesn't do this the
other eight audio logs are random logs like
andrew ryan talking about the vandalism of vending
machines or dr suchong testing out a new plasmid
you could have put these anywhere else in the game
and you wouldn't bat an eye as they fit anywhere
since their story isn't related to a specific
area it's not a bad decision to make these kind of
audio logs but it's clear that it makes it harder
to fill the others with more content about the
actual level it makes the medical pavilion seem
only about dr steinman and not the other people
in the pavilion thankfully the environment does
attempt to assist them in some ways but the rest
of the level lacks in any sort of story outside
of steinman this also isn't a level issue but more
of a whole game issue sometimes it always feels
like the world revolves around specific key people
and never anyone else our next level is a great
example of the opposite as neptune's bounty has no
end boss well sort of we'll get to that regardless
there are 19 audio logs in here and there's a very
diverse cast of characters within them as most of
them have between three to five logs each on top
of this majority of the logs add to the level's
ecosystem neptune's bounty was used as a cover-up
for a man named frank fontaine and his smuggling
ring many items inside rapture were considered
contraband as that would disrupt everything
rapture was built for and a large majority of
these audio logs aren't about one person but the
area as a whole such as when tenenbaum discovered
that slug we talked about earlier this links to
the creation of adam but also adds to the level
itself as this discovery was found here there's
also an audio log about a man named sullivan who
is a detective for andrew ryan who's trying to
find evidence against fontaine his audio logs
show the steps during his case as he attempts
to interrogate a smuggler of fontaine's we
can actually find the location of where this
interrogation happened in the level and this
also relates to the level as a whole again as this
is where fontaine does his smuggling so it would
make sense that a detective would be here this is
the weird problem with bioshock's audio logs but i
do want to make one thing very clear i do not hate
the concept of these logs there are great ways of
providing lore and world building to the game even
if they really shouldn't exist as we discussed
earlier plus they're audio logs not notes meaning
the player can walk around and explore the level
while listening to it rather than sitting still
and reading text however it's very clear that
there is some favoritism and inconsistency with
these audio logs where one area will have most of
the logs be about one character another may have
it be about the actual level and sometimes it's
neither it can make the story harder to follow at
times as events may occur earlier than when they
get explained and can also be the opposite where
something gets explained but then is shown to the
player later with the hopes that they remember it
getting back to the actual story neptune's bounty
is the next level we come across then as i said
earlier there is technically no boss in the level
at least bioshock's version of a boss as peach
wilkins doesn't have that audio log treatment
that many others got like dr steinman he only
gets three audio logs throughout the game so
it's clear he wasn't intended to be a boss or
main character of an area just a roadblock for
the player to go around this is further reinforced
by him denying us access to smuggler's hideout and
subsequently atlas's family until we can get him
a research camera i'm not the only person to say
this but from a story and gameplay perspective
this camera is very video gamey the fact that a
camera is able to analyze genetic material from
a simple picture is a possible stretch that i'm
willing to just barely forgive but it is in no way
entertaining to start a fight with a camera so you
can snapshot a picture of your enemy then get back
to fighting at the end of the day it's a really
small part of the game so i tend not to dwell on
this too much the fight that follows though has
always been a blast to do as it forces you to
get creative with your plasmids incinerate can
be used to open up more doorways which double as
cover and sources of eve and ammo furthermore you
can make this encounter much more entertaining if
you picked up the security bullseye from earlier
and don't even get me started about new game
plus as this makes this encounter even better
peaches is a bullet sponge however and does take
numerous hits to die from pretty much anything
but it does add to the intensity of the fight so i
didn't really mind it after somehow making it out
alive we arrive at smuggler's hideout where the
core of fontaine smuggling ring is located despite
it being the shortest level in bioshock it does
an amazing job showing off its environment as all
these boxes we see throughout the level are the
contraband fontaine was smuggling in we also do get
to see a flashback appear on screen when we enter
the area this isn't the first time we've seen one
and it won't be the last but it's relevant later
so we'll leave it for now it's also here where we
finally meet up with atlas and help him rescue his
family we let atlas through the door and we watch
as he attempts to free his family ninja ryan comes
on the radio and mocks us saying maybe you could
warn him or if only you could do something except
just stand there and watch him die on its own it's
exactly as it sounds but i've always found this to
have a double meaning after knowing the ending of
the game but just like the flashbacks and the tons
of other things we've talked about before today
we'll talk about that later we run down the
stairs to help atlas but he is overwhelmed
by splicers and needs to fall back but as we
approach the sub to finish the job he started
it explodes in front of us this is a turning point
for the game atlas the man who saved us and who we
can consider to be a dear friend of ours had just
watched his family die in front of him atlas and
now the player will want revenge for this and
the only person to enact that on is andrew ryan
that's why our next objective is to find the
bathysphere in rolling hills as this will take
us right to andrew ryan himself our next level
arcadia is simultaneously where the middle of the
game starts and also where it starts to plummet in
regards to the story from a gameplay perspective
this is just like the previous levels but with new
plasmids new enemies more upgrades and different
environments i thoroughly enjoyed the gameplay
when going through these sections but it carries
the levels as there isn't much story to go off of
however i will admit that there is the occasional
audio log sprinkled in the next few levels that
is very important to understanding the backstory
of rapture and that there is a very unique sense
of style to these places as they all serve very
unique purposes arcadia is a literal forest of
trees which is how rapture is able to produce
oxygen despite being hundreds of feet under the
water however the majority of the audio logs in
arcadia are dedicated to one person julie langford
the creator of the arcadia forest except she's not
a main boss like steinman in fact she helps us
which is a nice change of pace but her audio logs
don't really add much substance one talks about
her tests regarding this lazarus device and how
she wants to test the rosa gallica flower to see
its results but she was unable to due to a recent
lockdown if the bright colors and presentation
weren't obvious it's clear from the audio log
that these flowers will be important later even
if you didn't piece that together she'll have you
go fetch one anyway so it doesn't matter if you
caught on or not another talks about this cult
with an arcadia called the saturnine except it's
just about how they steal her equipment and how
they believe they're touched by the gods we do get
to see this cult in the game as all the houdini
spoilers in arcadia are a part of the group but
nothing else is developed they're just a cult
with no motivation and no real reason to exist
as from what we gather from the audio logs they
just drink human blood and plasmids steal julie's
research materials and are avoided by many of the
people in rapture as they brutally kill anyone who
isn't a part of them the question is though why
well if the wiki has anything to go off of it was
discovered that this cult was put into the game
very late in development and thus the devs ran
out of time to add any proper backstory to them
while i will at least recognize that there was an
attempt to add backstory assuming that article is
true it wasn't present in the full release thus i
can only go off of what we have in game this same
sort of storytelling though occurs all the way up
until we meet andrew ryan where there is that lack
of substance in the audio log save for a few key
logs at specific points everything we have to do
was made by the devs to add length to the game and
extend its gameplay once again taking everything
into account i don't mind this as the gameplay was
fun and i'll gladly take another couple hours of
it but when only looking at the story it's clear
we're being dragged along and constantly stalled
for the sake of run time to get to andrew ryan
from here we need to get through arcadia except
andrew ryan shuts off some of the oxygen so we
need to turn it back online with the help of julie
to turn it on we need to create the lazarus vector
julie was working on so we need to go from arcadia
to the farmers market to grab the materials
then go back to arcadia to put it together we
then have to hold out from a never-ending wave of
splicers as they attempt to shut down the device
after this we travel to fort frolic to find that
bathysphere only for the artist and serial killer
sander cohen to interrupt us after dealing with
him we make it to hephaestus a large industrial
power plant where we can go to andrew ryan's
office only for it to be locked to turn off this
electrical lock and get into his office we need
to blow up the power plant using a literal bomb
this takes around 4 or so hours to complete
which doesn't seem like a long time until you
realize this campaign's run time is close to 10
hours that's also being extremely generous given
the quality of the bioshock remasters is awful and
continues to crash and this game doesn't have any
consistent auto saves as they only trigger when
you enter a new level so assuming you get wrapped
up in gameplay and forget to save like i did you
might be losing a couple minutes to a whole hour
of progress so if anything it's actually less than
10 hours but still it's clear that a large portion
of the game is within these levels technically you
could argue that the first few levels do the exact
same thing as it does take quite a bit of time to
get to smuggler's hideout but not only are these
levels short as that whole sequence takes around
half the time the levels themselves are covered in
numerous audio logs related to the area or the
main boss of said area we've already discussed
before how arcadia does attempt to do the same
but fails by not providing enough substance the
farmer's market suffers from the exact same fate
as arcadia and hephaestus has a couple important
logs that are helpful to understanding the
downfall of rapture but fort frolic and sandrer
cohen are probably the only exception as sander
cohn is actually a really entertaining villain
and there is one extremely important audio
log that has relevance to the end of the game
sander cohen is extremely creepy and also a bit
sad at the same time he's a poet composer sculptor
and playwright he's clearly talented in the
realm of art but he too was subjected to the same
problems many had thanks to adam where steinman
became more infatuated with his work thanks to
adam as he attempted to erase all the problems
he had sander cohen would use this opportunity
to also enhance his craft he created artwork
from his victims by covering them in plaster and
setting them up in various poses it's horrifying
especially when you discover that they're actual
people as they bleed when you hit them as i said
he's creepy and his mannerisms and speech reflect
this too but he's also quite the sad person as his
audio logs and even some dialogue from andrew ryan
point to him seeing us as a spark he needed to
keep going the reason sandra cohen keeps us here
is that he needed help completing his masterpiece
a full four-picture display of his colleagues who
betrayed him next to a ton of bodies it's our job
to kill his colleagues and take their pictures i
do like how the pictures we take with the camera
are the actual photos and not some preset photo
the devs had in place so nice touch when we put
the third photo in the picture frame he freaks out
claiming that we are doubting his work in his fit
of rage he has numerous spider splicers attack us
he calms down after a while and does apologize
for the unnecessary outburst but it's clear that
he does not like people who dislike his work
by us helping cohen and seeing his masterpiece
through to the end we can possibly give him the
strength he needed to keep going with his artwork
and convey to him that he is indeed an excellent
artist it also seems that he may have planned to
kill andrew ryan at some point as one audio log
says that he wants to create a requiem for him
it's also during this level where we uncover
a very important scene of jasmine jolene who
we find out is andrew ryan's mistress
who's talking about her recent pregnancy
i'm sorry mr ryan i didn't know i didn't
know fontaine had something to do with it
what are you doing no no don't
play i love you no no wait no
that creepy doctor tenenbaum promised me it wasn't
gonna be a real pregnancy they just take the egg
out once mr ryan and i had oh i needed the money
so bad but i know mr ryan's gonna suss it out
no i wasn't being careful i'm gonna know
i sold the mr ryan's gonna be so mad at me
from what we gather it seems that andrew ryan had
discovered what occurred and beat her to death
with a pipe this incident just like many we have
discovered today will be relevant later but not
too much later as after running through the power
plant crafting the bomb and destroying the power
we can finally come face to face with the man
himself
this is what makes bioshock so hard to speak
about as so much of this game revolves around
this key moment and summarizing the journey here
in just a few short sentences is a disservice to
the effort that went into creating this plot twist
right before this we actually get to see a room
that andrew ryan was working in trying to piece
together what was going on he was confused why
there was some random person who just happened to
survive a plane crash right next to the entrance
to rapture and who is capable of defeating all
that he throws at him by the time we arrive
ryan manages to uncover the truth we're a sleeper
agent for atlas we from birth were created to be
this way that child of jasmine's that tenenbaum
took from her was us she paid jasmine for the
baby and conditioned the child to respond to
the phrase would you kindly meaning not only
was atlas lying to us we the player never had any
freedom in our choices and to top it all off were
ryan's son in some ways it's almost poetic someone
who preaches about men choosing and slaves obeying
has a son who is the complete opposite of him ryan
a man and his son a slave as if this plot twist
wasn't already bad enough the game isn't done yet
is when we take ryan's genetic key and put it into
the override we stop rapture from self-destructing
but now give control of rapture to atlas who is
actually frank fontaine this wouldn't have been
as good if it was anyone but fontaine the one who
ran the smuggling ring in neptune's bounty and
the one who worked with tenenbaum to condition
us was the guy who saved us the whole time that
room from earlier also shows us some of the
experiments jack underwent before being sent out
of rapture such as when dr suchong forced us to snap
a dog's neck because he said the phrase bioshock
without a doubt has one of the best if not the
best plot twist in gaming history from the moment
we have started the game we had no free will the
present we were given sparked the plane crash
so even before we could play the game we were
being controlled video games as a whole give the
player a choice it could be small choices like
how to kill the enemy in front of you or it could
be a large choice like the ending of a game but
bioshock took this idea and twisted it completely
by tricking the player into thinking they had the
freedom of choice when in fact the only choice
they were given was when to turn the game off
this revelation also ties into four things i've
noticed over the years and i've always wondered
if they were intentional or not firstly jack
has a tattoo of chains on his wrist possibly
signifying that he's a slave to atlas next is when
atlas's family who we eventually discovered didn't
actually exist blows up in the bathysphere
andrew ryan says maybe you could warn him
if only you could do something except just stand
there and watch him die at this time in the game
ryan doesn't know who we are so this wasn't
intended to be a double meaning but i believe
the devs made him say this on purpose as this
line can be interpreted as us once again being
a slave to atlas with no way to do anything about
it thirdly when we meet the little sister at the
medical pavilion atlas never says the words would
you kindly it's possible that not even tenenbaum
knew of atlas's true identity and if he had said
that phrase over the radio she would have caught
on immediately this is something fontaine tries
to do throughout the story and that's to play
the long game by convincing us that his family
died in the bathysphere we made our bond with
him even stronger as we now have a common goal but
that's exactly what fontaine wanted the last thing
i noticed was some symbolism in the first location
minutes into the game as there's a statue holding
up a ball with the words welcome to rapture on
it this is easily a reference to atlas the greek
giant who was forced to hold up the world for all
eternity this could be seen as a foreshadowing of
atlas trying to hold up the world of rapture by
defeating ryan and being the leader of the city
but it's also a reference to atlas's demise as
in greek mythology this was atlas's punishment
so this could be foreshadowing atlas's punishment
in game as he just made us an enemy all of these
might be completely wrong but the fact that they
line up so well with the game's themes and story
make it impossible to see it as a coincidence from
its plot twist to its symbolism it's one of the
best writing i've ever seen however we're still
not done with the game yet fontaine has betrayed
us and without any real objective anymore it's
only fair that we enact the same revenge again
but on the man who actually deserves it during the
reveal of fontaine he says goodbye and launches an
army of security bots to chase us during our
escape a little sister appears and guides us
to safety before falling down the vent shaft we
awake and then discover that we are in a secret
room in rapture where the little sisters relax
and play together it's a really cute moment as
we can see all the little sisters interacting with
one another tenenbaum then informs us that she was
able to reduce some of the mental conditioning
that fontaine put on us but we aren't completely
cured to achieve this we need to head to dr ssuchong's
laboratory and find his cure for it fontaine now
the head of rapture notices that we're awake and
attempts to shut us down but only ends up being
able to lower our health a bit by making our heart
stop momentarily it's a lot better than being
completely manipulated but he can still control
us in some way so we definitely need that cure
the location where this cure is found is a place
called olympus heights where all the super rich
stayed in luxury apartments many characters we've
already talked about today like tennenbaum dr
suchong and even sander cohen lived in these
apartments i've always found it interesting how
these apartments are right next to apollo square
which is known for housing the poor and homeless
you can even tell from the railroad station next
to each area as the area near olympus heights
is quite pristine given the circumstances and
the one in apollo square is extremely run down
both the audio logs and the environment will tell
us that there was clearly a revolution starting
here and at the head of this was atlas in order to
avoid suspicion and hide under the radar fontaine
faked his own death and changed his name and face
to atlas we learned in arcadia that atlas was at
one point a politician but he claimed those days
were over it seemed that fontaine was using the
poor as his army and there is numerous audio
logs to back this theory up andrew ryan wanted
to create the perfect society but it fell victim
to social status and given his own policies within
rapture there wasn't much opportunity to crawl
back to the middle class those who were rich
succeeded and those who were poor suffer
just like every other society in existence
fontaine sees this opportunity to gather an army
of like-minded individuals and use them to do his
bidding going back to neptune's bounty we have a
couple audio logs from peaches that talk about how
he disliked ryan and preferred fontaine's way
of running things at least initially until he
realized that fontaine might actually be worse
than ryan this really shows that even rapture
was doomed to fail as a society the only way it
was possible to save this city was for ryan to
help the poor and make sure everyone was happy but
given his own beliefs and the beliefs of rapture
that was never going to happen the downfall
of rapture didn't happen overnight it was a
long string of events that progressively got worse
and worse the adam addiction the mistreatment of
the poor the manipulation of fontaine the actual
culture surrounding rapture all of it contributed
to its demise getting back to the story we end
up finding the cure for our mental conditioning
and allowed jack complete freedom for the first
time in his life one thing that's important to
note is his freedom because it's not like he was
completely controlled he still did things in his
life before coming to rapture but he was never
completely free as fontaine could easily change
that by saying one simple phrase while gathering
the cure we also found a dead body on the table
and discovered that it's dr suchong's quite
ironic that dr suchong died to his own creation
he was of course the original creator of the
big daddies and was the one who created that
defense mechanism in them that attacks anyone who
hurts the little sisters good to see that he's
dead given how much pain he caused people after
finding the cure we can now kill fontaine except
before we get a chance to heal locks the door of
the educational facility which is only unlocked
via a big daddy which means we need to become a
big daddy despite how bothersome this area can be
in regards to its confusing layout and plethora
of enemies from a lore perspective it's quite
intriguing as this is the facility where the big
daddies and little sisters were made one thing
that's been missing from this game so far is the
who the big daddies are and how they were made and
thankfully this area answers that question it
seems that the big daddies are people who had
their skin and organs grafted to the suits which
may explain why they can't take them off in jack's
case he didn't need to graft his skin and organs
to the suit as he just needed to trick the system
into thinking he was a big daddy which is why
he isn't injured during the process however he
does need a voice module so he can sound like one
and just by looking at the device it definitely
doesn't look safe after becoming a big daddy we
help out a little sister who gives us a syringe
and unlocks the final locked door to fontaine
where we can now finally start the boss fight and
both this and the endings of bioshock are honestly
quite bad fontaine is a giant creature now flowing
with adam and while i'm willing to just barely
believe something like this is possible the fight
overall is just bad all you do during the fight is
shoot him until his health is gone and then when
he returns to his machine to gather more adam you
stab him with the syringe and you do this 4 times
until he dies you would think after the second
time he would stop recharging his adam this way
but apparently not the boss fight does ramp up in
difficulty as the security bots and splicers come
to his aid but it's sort of hard to ignore the
giant naked man trying to kill you especially
when he functions just like a big daddy and stuns
you when you're hit after defeating him he'll
smack you one more time and all the little sisters
will come out and aid you by stabbing him which
admittedly is pretty cool afterward the game goes
into one of three endings and the conditions of
the ending depend on whether or not you harvested
or saved the little sisters one ending is when you
save all of them the other is when you harvest all
of them and a third is if you do a mix of both you
don't need to rescue every single little sister
but out of the ones you interacted with within
the game you do have to save them i do like the
happy ending where all the little sisters grow up
and live normal lives before all meeting again to
be with you on your deathbed but the other is just
bizarre as jack takes control of rapture for
himself and uses the splicers as an army to
overtake the surface and launch a nuke like the
ending started okay but ramped up in intensity
immediately why does jack need a nuke why bother
killing those on the surface what was even the
point of this ending this just like the morality
of harvesting and rescuing the little sisters was
something the developers wish they had improved
on for the final release regardless we have made
it to the end of the game and thus finish the
story of bioshock this game is without a doubt
one of the best of all time it truly has one of
the best stories in the gaming industry and is
one i wish i could experience again for the first
time bioshock has an incredible level of detail
put into its story from its world building to its
story of specific characters this couple with its
incredible plot twist makes this a very hard game
to beat when it comes to comparing its stories
it's one game i will always recommend without
hesitation and was the perfect start to a brandnew series
bioshock 2 is perfection it took
what was wrong with bioshock 1 and changed it
for the better but it also kept its strongest
narrative devices in the game making it feel
like how a bioshock game should this ultimately
created a perfect version of bioshock that i feel
doesn't get enough credit so today i want to
discuss why i think that without further ado
let's get started as always we need to start at
the beginning a cutscene showcases that we are
in 1958. if you recall from the lore that is only
a year before the new year's attacks in 1959. so
currently things should be quite civil and for the
most part they are we see a first person view of a
big daddy talking with a little sister to which he
follows her around the halls she ends up running
on ahead before getting caught by some thugs
just like any big daddy would he decimates the
thugs with ease before being hypnotized afterwards
though a woman named sofia lamb enters the room
we get a sneak peek at the big daddy guiding her
and it's a model we haven't seen yet in the series
on top of that the little girl has a name eleanor
throughout the series we aren't told little
sister's name so this was done intentionally to
paint her as an important character even further
we actually see the big daddy remove his helmet
this is also a first for the series as we know big
daddies were regular people who had modifications
done to their bodies so they could fit the role of
the big daddy such as voice modification mental
conditioning and the grafting of the skin to the
suit itself but this doesn't seem to be the case
the only character who's capable of doing this is
jack and bioshock 1 but as we know he only needed
to seem like a big daddy so he could bypass the
facility's lockdown if you want to see more of
this i did talk about bioshock 1 in a previous
video which will be linked at the end of this
one or in the i in the top right right now so
questions are already flooding the player's
mind and it's enough to either get them hooked
immediately or at least get their attention mind
you this is only three minutes into the game so
we're starting off quite strong bioshock 1 had
the element of surprise as the player wasn't
accustomed to rapture just yet that's why it's
sudden reveal landed so well but doing that again
wouldn't have the same effect so bioshock 2 needed
to ramp up the intensity and not only does the
intro start off incredibly strong it keeps going
as the character we play throughout the game is
a big daddy words can't describe how excited i was
when seeing this there is no doubt in my mind that
at least once throughout a playthrough of bioshock
1 you must have thought how cool it would have
been to play as one, well our prayers have been
answered as playing as the big daddy is arguably
the greatest feeling in the series from the actual
moment-to-moment gameplay to the interactions with
the little sisters the big daddy is such a great
character for the player to control as if all this
wasn't great already the game introduces the
newest character to the roster the big sister
these two represent a sort of dichotomy battling
over a common goal quite early in the game we take
our first plasmid and come across a little sister
since we're a big daddy our duty is to obviously
protect her except the big sister swipes her away
from us the problem is that the big sisters were
designed to also protect the little sisters so
firstly where did she even come from but secondly
why are they actively working against us despite
having a common goal bioshock as a series has
never shielded away from secrecy mystery and
confusion especially in its early moments
already within just a few minutes we're given
multiple breadcrumb trails and while not forced
to follow said trail why wouldn't you after
going through this intro who is the big sister
who are we why aren't we a normal big daddy who's
eleanor and who is sofia lamb these questions
are the driving force behind why the player
continues deeper into the game bioshock 2 had
a tough job of continuing the series after the
very satisfying conclusion of the previous game
it also had to get the player interested
despite giving all of its secrets away in
that previous game and somehow bioshock 2 nailed
it perfectly some games have been able to pull
this off before but only few have been truly able
to do this within a couple minutes of game time
and the fact that bioshock 2 can replicate the
same mysterious feeling of bioshock 1 with the
added penalty of having its vast world building
already known by the player deserves some praise
so now that i'm done rambling about the game's
mystery i think it's time to finally explain
that mystery i've always been a sucker for lore in
games if it wasn't evident by the videos on this
channel and bioshock 2's newly added concepts
in world building are moderately brilliant
just like bioshock 1 the majority of the story
will come from audio diaries random devices we can
find throughout the world however bioshock 1 ran
into an issue with these devices many of the audio
diaries focused on key characters whether that was
the main boss of an area like dr steinman or was
a part of rapture's high society like tenenbaum
and andrew ryan it felt like rapture only revolved
around a few people and that never sat right
with me bioshock 2 changes this completely as
while some notable characters will have numerous
appearances throughout the game like sofia lamb
andrew ryan and tenenbaum there's also a large
number of audio logs made by just random people
who had way more world building than bioshock 1
ever did we'll circle back to him in a moment but
a good example is mark meltzer his audio diaries
detail his investigation into rapture and his
daughter sydney as he believes his daughter was
kidnapped and brought here for an unknown reason
originally it seems like just a one-off diary
but not only does just this one diary explain
that people from the surface have found
an invaded rapture but he has more diaries
that show up throughout the game and it makes you
want to see the outcome of his investigation like
i said even if it was just a one-off diary the
fact that people like mark can even find rapture
is incredible to begin with rapture was built to
be away from society both far and deep enough that
only those who were invited would know yet somehow
random people are able to find it and that's a big
issue just this one diary finally provided an
astronomical amount of world building and makes
rapture feel like a living breathing city besides
the miscellaneous audio diaries a good portion
of them still deal with a lot of information
that is necessary to understanding what's going
on so the intro was in 1958 but the game actually
takes place 10 years later in 1968. we are subject
delta and alpha series big daddy not only are
we a part of the first line of big daddies but
we're the first ever big daddy to be bonded with a
little sister on top of this being an alpha series
is quite different than being a regular big daddy
firstly alpha series big daddies don't have the
skin grafted to their suit which explains why
delta could take off his helmet in the intro
furthermore the alpha series is only intended to
bond with one little sister during their creation
the person inside the suit was fitted with an
unbreakable psychological bond with one little
sister should this bond be broken by the death of
the little sister or the separation of the two for
an extended period of time the alpha series will
either collapse and enter a coma-like state or be
driven mad with rage one of the audio diaries even
talks about someone seeing one of the alpha series
big daddies crying at a gatherer's garden because
they couldn't find their little sister this idea
clearly had many drawbacks as the big daddies
would be completely useless should the little
sister die this is why they changed the typical
big daddies we see more frequently in bioshock 1.
ones who still protect the little sisters but
don't have a specific bond with a particular
one making them a bit more useful this unbreakable
bond we just discussed is why delta is so adamant
on finding eleanor when he awakes but clearly he
wasn't just a suit of armor all his life as we
know all big daddies were humans at some point in
delta's case he was just a deep-sea diver on the
surface who accidentally came across rapture he
actually had an article written in the paper about
him ryan didn't believe this story and thought
that he was a spy so he had him incarcerated his
old life would then come to an end when he was
selected to be a part of the big daddy program
leaving his old name and identity behind being
only known as delta after the cutscene in the
intro delta wakes up after the events of
bioshock 1 so andrew ryan and fontaine are
already dead the first words we hear upon waking
up are from a familiar voice tenenbaum it seems
that even though rapture is practically a barren
wasteland she decided to stay behind or at least
that's what it seems like tenenbaum actually
came back to rapture thanks to sofia lamb
rapture is an extremely captivating place not
just in ideals but in location substitute out
that objectivism that andrew ryan prodded into
the city and swapped that with literally anything
and you can get a ultimate utopia of that ideal
rapture is a secluded place away from the rest
of the world so literally anything involved with
rapture could have blossomed from such a location
like let's say a cult rapture in bioshock 2 is
now under new management with sofia lamb being
the leader who has rallied the people behind the
banner of the family you may actually recognize
sophia as throughout the first game there was a
poster showing rapture's best and brightest and
in the back resides sofia before and during her
time in rapture she was a clinical psychiatrist
anger ryan had invited her to rapture so that
she could provide counseling to the isolated
members of rapture overall it sounded like a great
deal for both parties involved but sophia quickly
realized that the cause of this problem was the
person who hired her to solve it andrew ryan see
rapture under ryan was built around objectivism
something i had completely neglected to bring
up in the previous video so thank you all the
comments for mentioning that to me objectivism
is defined as quote the concept of man as a heroic
being with his own happiness as the moral purpose
of his life with productive achievement as his
noblest activity and reason as his only absolute
but sophia had a more altruistic look on life
as she had hoped to enlighten the citizens of
rapture through a common good she would do
this by providing free therapy to the poor
and intentionally losing at poker so she could
spread her wealth to the less fortunate anger
ryan actively wanted the people to push themselves
and seek their true greatness on their own without
anyone hindering their progress but sofia was
actively going against that by helping others
this caused the two to clash heads on multiple
occasions even having live debates on specific
topics and it was also during this time that sofia
was actively helping the poor and fontaine was
also trying to undermine ryan using fontaine
futuristics so when it was discovered that
both fontaine and ryan were dead it made sense
that she became the newest owner her altruistic
outlook on life also helped her gain that favor
as the people of rapture saw her as a kind woman
willing to help those who were less fortunate but
she knew this wouldn't last she would either be
overtaken by some other force of nature or she
would die from natural causes so to continue
her goal she ended up teaching her daughter in
hopes of becoming her perfect vessel eleanor is
her daughter yes the little sister that delta had
bonded with is none other than the new queen of
rapture's daughter it's such a great twist and
it raises the stakes of our missions tenfold so
far this is the story of rapture in bioshock
2 but i've neglected to bring up tenenbaum
as i said tenenbaum did leave rapture and so
did all the little sisters but she discovered
that more girls were disappearing so she came back
to rapture to find out someone was making little
sisters again so she came down here to put an end
to it as you remember tenenbaum was the creator of
the little sisters but after she realized the pain
in suffering this cause she regretted her actions
and dedicated her time to stopping what she
created but now she has to do it all over again
this is the full complete backstory that sets the
foundation of bioshock 2. it's quite a lot and can
get complex at times but this is exactly what
i was looking for i wanted bioshock 2 to take
the already established story of bioshock 1 and
make that the foundation for the sequel and this
integration exceeded my expectations so far we've
been getting a little ahead of ourselves so let's
dial it back a bit and continue where we left off
in game currently we're still in the early minutes
of the game and already sofia and her cult like
following is starting to show itself as there
are paintings tributes and murals dedicated to her
there's no shortage of these in bioshock 2 truly
showing how far her influence goes in rapture
and alternatively how alone and outnumbered we
are again accompanying these tributes is a book
called unity and metamorphosis it's all about the
creation of a perfect paradise through unity and
the abandonment of the self this also coincides
with all the imagery and messages of butterflies
and being reborn just as a caterpillar is reborn
into a butterfly a butterfly is vastly different
compared to a caterpillar which is why it's
considered two different insects despite being
the same thing sophia planned on using eleanor as
a vessel for her ideologies by basically shutting
her away from the world while she teaches her she
would then show the family eleanor and how she is
the first utopian who is able to abandon herself
and become truly free the problem is that sophia
has to convince the rest of rapture to do the same
and while many are on her side aligning herself
with her is a lot different than changing your
way of thinking permanently thankfully depending
on how you look at it sofia did find a rather
interesting discovery sophia discovered the story
of jack and realized that this mental conditioning
could be used to make people uphold the common
good this proves that sofia is just as flawed as
everyone else she is literally following in the
footsteps of fontaine and is considering using
a type of conditioning that reprograms the brain
and forces people not to think for themselves just
like we talked about before this is another
example of bioshock 2 taking key parts from
the previous game and reworking it in the sequel
now the phrase would you kindly isn't seen as a
way to manipulate someone to do your bidding but
it's seen as a necessary step to be able to live
freely in a utopia it's these slight twists on
already familiar material that makes the story
very engaging again continuing through the level
we finally get to face off against the big sister
and it's here and a few other places later in the
game via audio diaries where we discover where
these big sisters came from these big sisters were
originally little sisters the adam in their body
became too problematic as they grew older and thus
the older sisters were moved into different roles
we also find out that it was the big sisters
who were abducting the new little sisters from
the surface which explains the vast population of
little sisters still in rapture again there isn't
any other lore besides this but it does answer a
fairly good question in regards to what happens
when the sisters get older irrational games could
have easily just said that because rapture is so
large we didn't rescue all the little sisters
thus why they're still populating the city but
this approach to its world building was a much
better choice so nice job as we approach the
end of the first area we encounter sophia for the
first time very similarly to how we encounter ryan
except instead of atlas trying to help us it's
tenenbaum she then explains that she can help us
get to eleanor or she can see through the camera
in our helmets except i'm not really even sure why
they brought this up as it's never used again
we meet tenenbaum one time in person and then
afterwards we never hear another word from her
we get more info on her whereabouts and time and
rapture from audio diaries again which is a shame
as these audio diaries tell us a lot of important
information that i would have loved for her to
elaborate on now to be fair these audio logs
are in the dlc which we'll talk about later
but still i wish that she would have had much
more of an appearance this game instead we're
going to be guided by augustus sinclair and i
100 blame bioshock 1 for this because i did not
trust him the entire game he feels the exact same
role as atlas a guy we don't know who just wants
to help us for seemingly no reason but the whole
time he was talking i was just waiting for him to
backstab us but it never came true upon entering
the second area we hear eleanor's voice and
discover that she can talk to us telepathically
and is actively trying to aid us by bringing us
gifts and plasmids it's not clear how she can do
this but it's explained later one thing you'll
notice from playing this game is the lack of
levels in bioshock 2. the game only has 9 areas
compared to its predecessor's 14 and while that's
not a large difference it's still a lesser amount
but what bioshock 2 lacks in quantity it makes
up for in quality each of these levels is 3 4 5
levels high filled with rubble objects enemies and
other gear for the player to look at these places
feel lived in and real which is always a nice
feeling you'll be spending much more time in these
levels individually than compared to bioshock 1.
both games did take me around the same time to
complete yet one game had less levels than the
other meaning i was spending more time in those
levels engaging with the environment and dealing
with puzzles and all the enemies it threw at me
bioshock 1 also did feel quite linear at times
places like the proving grounds and the medical
pavilion were great but some of the levels felt
way too linear for the genre all the levels in
bioshock 2 are completely non-linear you'll be
constantly backtracking to the same places and
not only does this add to the gameplay loop of
finding new enemies in the same locations but it
also plays into the story and how it's continually
trying to reinforce how large these areas within
rapture are and how expansive this city really is
my only complaint is the odd amount of similarity
between some of the levels as sometimes it's hard
to determine what level you're really on besides
a few specific areas bioshock 1 really nailed
the diversity of the level to level gameplay to
where no level really looked the same i will admit
though that this is quite the subjective stance
however something that is objectively better than
before is the way the game handles the little
sisters in our last video talking about bioshock
1 i mentioned that while on paper the choice of
saving and harvesting the little sisters was cool
in practice it was extremely one-sided as
it favored rescuing the little sisters thus
ruining the choice of morality bioshock 2 reduces
the number of little sisters from 21 down to 12.
on top of this rescuing the little sister requires
you to defeat the big daddy protecting her then
escort her to two bodies in the level to extract
adam from once that's done only then can you
rescue them this is made way more difficult thanks
to bioshock 2's amp difficulty the game isn't
impossible but you start out with a max of 5 eve
and health slots rather than your 9 in bioshock 1.
your weapons also don't feel nearly as powerful
sometimes and enemies do hit a lot harder
plus there's also more big daddies as you'll be
constantly fighting more alpha series versions as
we get closer to the game's epilogue furthermore
every 4 little sisters that you rescue or harvest
will spawn a big sister who while does drop 40
adam is without a doubt the hardest enemy in the
game after everything is all said and done upon
looking at the numbers the actual difference isn't
that far off it's actually less than the previous
game with a difference of 90 adam according to
the wiki but the tasks required to get that adam
makes harvesting seem like the much better option
as if all this wasn't bad enough already something
we discover from the audio logs later in the game
is that the little sisters despite being immortal
do experience some degree of pain as one fell over
a railing and broke her leg and when they tried
to snap it back into place it was clear from her
facial reactions that she was experiencing pain
makes you think about the next time you unload a
few rockets near her when you try to take down the
big daddy relating back to the story this is what
irrational games had intended for the first game
giving the player an easy but morally wrong option
and a hard but morally right option to see
if it's enough to break the player's values
is the struggle to hold off waves of splicers
enough to make you snap and just take the atom
for yourself by force this idea also makes the
ending much more important but we'll get to that
later the fourth area of the game is poppers drop
and is our first instance of a boss-like character
similar to dr steinman from bioshock 1 in
this area we have grace holloway who runs
this section of rapture and is eagerly waiting to
kill us according to the audio logs we find about
her grace was a singer here in rapture who caught
the eye of a james who was enjoying her singing he
seemed to enjoy when people were real when it came
to rapture and willing to talk about its flaws
this caused him to be noticed by ryan and then
taken away never to be heard of again she would
then hear of sofia lam and how she was giving
away a free counseling and then was swindled into
her family she joined her group of people and
because of how important she was to sophia when
ryan eventually came for sophia and locked her up
in prison she gave eleanor to grace so that she
may look after her however this didn't last long
as eleanor was kidnapped and sold to the little
sisters orphanage which explains how she became a
little sister in the first place once she became
a little sister she would then bond to us and
we would then become her current guardian this
explains why grace is extremely mad at our arrival
in pauper's drop claiming that we stole eleanor
from her the reason this is relevant is because
all this information is key to understanding her
character and thus determining her fate at the
end of the level bioshock 2 introduces the option
of killing or sparing three key people and our
first is grace holloway when you enter grace's
quarters you're given the choice of killing or
sparing her it's quite easy to just kill her and
leave since she started fighting you but given
her backstory i ultimately decided to spare her
she was just a poor and lost woman down in rapture
and when sofia was able to bring her out of her
own hell of course she was going to help her as
much as she could plus we can't blame her for not
understanding the bond between eleanor and delta
neither wanted to become little sisters or big
daddies even as an alpha series model yes your
skin isn't grafted to the suit but you're still
heavily spliced with adam and of course as we know
most if not all the big daddies were unwilling
participants we never chose this life but grace
doesn't know that so we can't blame her for trying
to kill us if you spare her she goes on to say
that she was wrong about you she still believes
that sophia isn't a liar but she knows that she is
at least wrong about delta our second character is
stanley poole at dionysus park still continuing
to be altruistic sofia also had a hand in the
creation of the park which served as a both an art
and cultural exhibit hosted by sofia herself she
created this as both a way for her to undermine
ryan's ideals and also a way to promote her own
ryan's main philosophy with rapture was a city
without morals or sensors so naturally all art
should be accepted in rapture until sofia
started using this against him and started
showcasing art opposite of ryan's ideology this
of course led to her art being censored by the
general public showing that rapture was a place
that accepted these qualities but as long as ryan
agreed to it to make matters worse for ryan his
own version of this was arcadia from bioshock 1
except ryan charged his visitors whereas sofia
made this exhibit free to the public due to
this attack on his character ryan had enough of
lamb and sent a spy to infiltrate her network
this spy was stanley poole stanley was quite
successful in feeding information to ryan but
so much so that it led to sofia being imprisoned
he would then during this time used the money
sophia had to throw parties at the park in an
attempt to eradicate her funds however during
this time eleanor caught wind of these parties
and confronted stanley about it fearing he would
be caught he was the one who kidnapped eleanor
and gave her up to the little sisters orphanage
in the present day stanley has flooded the exhibit
fearing that sophia and the other members in the
family would rat him out as ryan's spy he stays
held up in there for years until delta arrives at
the park while we're only here to just pass by and
get to fontaine futuristic stanley refuses to let
us pass until we deal with all the little sisters
despite all the witnesses being dead stanley fears
that when the little sisters drain the victims
adam they'll discover the truth and relay the
info back to sofia so he wants us to get rid of
them but by helping the little sisters we can also
uncover the full story for ourselves what is shown
is the info we just previously went over with him
kidnapping eleanor and throwing massive parties
at sofia's expense when we approach stanley sophia
hops on the microphone and says that he is the
reason we're a big daddy and that she knew for
years that he was a spy we are now once again
given the option of killing or sparing him this
decision was probably the hardest one for me to
do stanley is responsible for our new life but he
wasn't the only one at fault he wrote the article
about delta being the mysterious deep-sea diver
the article didn't seem like it was malicious
ryan was the only one who saw delta as a threat
so the blame now goes to ryan but ryan just simply
imprisoned us it was sinclair who would then offer
us a job at fontaine futuristics as a performer
who tested plasmids in front of a live audience
these performances made him a candidate for the
big daddy program so sinclair is now to blame but
dr suchong and gilbert alexander created the big
daddy program so they're to blame as well do you
see where this is going no one person is truly
responsible for delta's new life it was just
coincidence after coincidence and he was just at
the wrong places at the wrong time every time you
could however claim that because he heard eleanor
and turned her into a little sister he should be
punished but this argument is quite shallow all
of these decisions that happened between us and
eleanor led to us being bonded together but
if something changed then we could have been
bonded with someone else say we arrived later
or even earlier to rapture then eleanor would
have likely never bonded with us so there is no
argument in saying that we should harm stanley
for how we treated eleanor because not only did we
not know her even prior to our own transformation
you could technically even argue that we should be
grateful to him for bringing us together although
i don't really subscribe to that idea either
despite this there is a lot of reasons to not
spare him and that is because of his other actions
like killing the witnesses and clearly showing
that he'll do whatever it takes including murder
to get his way it's due to this confliction that i
ultimately decided to spare stanley he wasn't the
sole reason we're a big daddy and the idea that we
should harm him for what he did to eleanor makes
no sense either our third and final character is
gilbert alexander his introduction starts off
quite different than what we're used to as we
hear an audio recording tell us to kill him and
then we see him piloting a security bot all while
yelling at a group of splicers this is quite the
twist as we have a man who is telling us to kill
him because he's going to become clinically insane
but then also having that new insane self tell us
not to kill him it's also during this level where
we can meet mark meltzer the guy who investigated
rapture so he could find his daughter or at least
what was left of him anyway it seems that despite
all he went through he was caught by sofia and
turned into a big daddy on the plus side however
according to the audio log that was found in
his body the little sister he bonded with was
his daughter cindy so at least they got to be
together forever at least until we killed him
you don't discover that this is mark until after
his death which makes you feel quite sad as you
just tore his daughter from him so i made it up
to mark by restoring his daughter to her former
self in hopes that she can have a brighter future
it's incredible how bioshock makes you care about
mark and cindy despite them rarely ever showing
up you know what happens to the little girls in
rapture so that makes the situation even worse
as we now finally got to see the other side of
the coin we're not able to see how the parents
react to their daughter being taken bioshock
1 did this as well with another individual
but i felt it was much better handled here
going back to gilbert since we have to decide his
fate the question is then what's his story well
gilbert alexander was a researcher at rapture who
specialized in robotic and mechanical engineering
he was also the creator of the alpha series big
daddies and was responsible for the unbreakable
bond that they have built into them as we know
it worked too well making them not as efficient
and protecting all the little sisters as it
only made them care about one this idea was
inevitably thrown out but due to his knowledge of
the bonding process and the manufacturing of the
suits he assisted dr sung in creating the new line
of big daddies after some time though he began to
feel guilty about his actions sofia used the skill
to manipulate him into being her own test subject
dr alexander has agreed to accept both measures of
the new utopian project he will become a kind of
genetic chimera host to all the minds of rapture
accessing their talents and memories via the adam
we have gathered and deriving in part from project
wyk i have developed a new set of behavioral
constraints dr alexander will live to promote the
common good she wanted to use gilbert as a test
subject to see if she could create the first
utopian being capable of losing self-interest
and being extremely loving and loyal to the
human race this however did not go as planned
i was to be sofia lamb's greatest achievement
a living composite of all raptures genius in the
body of a single man unfettered by self-interest
now i am nothing more to her than a failed
experiment my scores on tests of intelligence
and moral reasoning are still noteworthy
but declining sharply she has abandoned me and i
do not have long before psychosis takes me this
is what led to gilbert making the audio logs we
hear about how to kill him once he becomes insane
after entering the core of fontaine futuristics
we can see him in his final form which is this
giant amalgamation inside of a water tank it looks
awful we then for the final time have to decide
another person's fate this is the only person
in the game i killed and i also killed without
hesitation i deemed it as a mercy killing more
than anything this does become quite the tough
argument when you consider that it's possible that
after being clinically insane he enjoyed his new
life and thus killing him would have been a bad
thing it's ultimately his words against his own
and personally i'd rather believe the version that
was able to think more rationally rather than the
one that was mutated beyond human recognition
that's why i felt that it was a good idea to
kill him so i could rid him of his suffering and
allow him to finally die as a whole these choices
were really well done and judging from some of
the community discussions i have seen and many
have chosen the alternate solutions that i didn't
choose i read many posts saying that they killed
grace holloway for trying to fight them that they
killed stanley for turning us into a big daddy
and some even spared gilbert because they believed
that his past self wants to die but his present
self doesn't want to and thus they spared him this
shows that these choices were well written enough
that it wasn't clear what the best choice was in
the moment they should think about your decision
and what led to things being like how they are now
and that's once again extremely impressive after
dealing with gilbert we make it to persephone
which is rapture's prison system and is also
where we find eleanor as we approach her sofia
stops us and locks us out she goes on to explain
that eleanor wanted a father and tried to make one
again an audio log clears this up but basically
eleanor has the power to control the little
sisters and through this power she managed to
find a gene sample of delta she planned on using
this sample to revive delta through a vita chamber
and sure enough it worked this explains how we
survived the gunshot wound we didn't actually
survive eleanor just revived us she also used the
little sisters to contact tenenbaum so that she
could help us get back up on our feet now things
are starting to make a bit more sense but just
as we're about to be let inside sofia smothers
eleanor with a pillow temporarily stopping us due
to our unbreakable bond however it was only for a
specific amount of time as sophia obviously wants
to keep eleanor alive as that's literally her
daughter so it wasn't enough time to kill her
but it was enough to break our bond with her when
we awake we're strapped down and can't move but
eleanor lets us take control of one of the little
sisters so that we can unlock our own restraints
as simple as this sequence was it was probably
one of my favorites in the entire game as we got
to see the world through the eyes of the little
sister for the very first time and it truly shows
how deep the mental conditioning went they don't
even see the same world that we do it's completely
different this was more than likely made so that
the girls didn't have to see the horrors of the
real world and thus can continue to do their jobs
without being scared this explains why everything
is so clean and new in their world and why the
big sister suit isn't a diving suit but a dress
and why there's petals instead of blood when we do
extract the blood from the splices though it does
come back to the real world and i don't think this
happens to the girls i think it's just more of a
game design decision to remind us that we're still
in rapture meaning the girls after becoming little
sisters never see the real world again until
we save them this was such a great section and
really shows how badly their minds were altered
after using the little sister to gather the big
sister suit we give it to eleanor who uses it to
break out of her containment and then release us
as well we also get a plasmid that can summon her
from any location which is really cool as it shows
sophia that despite the bond being physically
broken their love for one another knows no bounds
by talking with eleanor we discover that she has
a plan which is to take sinclair's lifeboat up to
the surface except sofia is trying to stop us
while trying to thwart her plans it's stopping
us we run into sinclair again except time this is
not on good terms it seems that he was captured
and made into a big daddy we can hear his voice
over the radio getting more and more desperate as
he tries to find a way out of the suit he then
tells us to unlock the door and finish him off
even though he desperately wanted to live and be
on the surface again dying is better than being a
controlled test subject after getting the device
from sinclair and also helping eleanor rescue the
little sisters that are in the nearby wing we use
the little sisters by having them boil the water
underneath the lifeboat so it can rise i'll be
honest i don't remember if this was ever explained
in the entire series ever but the only thing i can
assume is that they're expelling the atom in their
systems which heats the water somehow as we finish
heating the lifeboat the explosives that sofia
planted explode and cause us to get knocked back
thankfully we're just barely able to latch onto
the lifeboat as it floats up and it's here where
we discover the ending of the game but it's done
a bit differently this time there are six possible
endings but it's all because of the combination of
two choices the harvesting and rescuing from
bioshock 1 returns again but the sparing and
killing of the previous characters is also a
factor there's actually a neat little flowchart
someone made to help visualize them sparing lives
actually has different weight depending on your
choices with the little sisters if you spared all
the girls then saving one character will give you
the best ending but if you harvest a couple of
little sisters then you must spare all of them
to get that same ending this goes even further
with the bad ending is when you harvest all the
little sisters sparing the three characters is
still not enough and then you're stuck in the bad
ending now this is only for determining whether or
not sofia lives the other decision is eleanor and
delta's fate if you rescue all the little sisters
then eleanor will drain delta's adam and transfer
it into her so that his memories and consciousness
can live inside of her and the two can be together
forever if you harvest all the little sisters
eleanor shows no remorse and drains all of his
adam for herself killing delta as she says that we
taught her not to let things go to waste however
these endings are different from bioshock 1 and
not just in the actual cutscenes but it's how it's
determined remember eleanor can control and look
through the eyes of the little sisters because of
this she was able to witness all the rescuing and
harvesting we did to them as well as the decisions
we made regarding the three important people we
discussed before and it's these decisions that
play into the ending of the game whereas bioshock
1 had a similar structure which changed the ending
based on our decisions with the sisters it's not
outlandish to find this a bit odd as some could
have simply just used the sisters for extra adam
to survive rapture and had no intentions of taking
the girls for themselves or using them in the
splashes to rule rapture but with bioshock 2 your
decisions don't affect you but your own daughter
just as a parent can influence their child's
behavior we as the parent influenced eleanor's
outlook on life such as whether or not people
should be forgiven for their past mistakes and a
bit more directly eleanor got to see how caring
and ruthless delta was like i said earlier when we
get the bad ending she explains how we taught her
not to let things go to waste and that bad people
should be punished for their actions no matter how
small or insignificant they were this adds another
layer to the endings overall as these aren't just
decisions that affect the ending of the game but
decisions that affect eleanor which then affect
the ending of the game this was mind-blowing when
i had looked into the endings and how they were
determined and it's just outright incredible while
the ending of bioshock 2 marks the end of the game
it's not really the end of the game as bioshock
2 came with a couple dlcs one of which was a side
story called minerva's den as opposed to the
main game minerva's then takes a bit longer to
set up the story instead of our main character
being subject delta we now play a subject sigma
another alpha series big daddy as we approach a
tunnel it gets blown up and we're sent into the
sea floor we hear a man on the radio named charles
milton porter who instructs us to find the thinker
we then eventually get introduced to reed wall
both him and porter were the founders of this
device called the thinker which is great except
we don't know what it is of course in typical
bioshock fashion an audio log explains it instead
the thinker is a giant computer that uses atom to
process data at the speed of thought it's the sole
reason that rapture can even operate it's quite a
neat device but both reid and porter discovered it
could do so much more this is what caused a split
between the two founders reid wanted to use the
thinker as a prediction machine so it can bet on
the ball games and see the changes in the stock
market but porter wanted to create artificial
intelligence but more specifically he just wanted
to replicate the mind of his dead wife pearl who
died during a german bombing during our travels
through minerva's den we can also find some
audio logs of tenenbaum which explains why she
disappeared during the main story she was trying
to find a cure for adam, adam and the sickness
that comes with repeated use is the main reason
rapture turned out this way in the first place
and if tenenbaum can find a cure she can not only
help those who are still alive within rapture but
also be able to take this and the plasmids to the
surface with the safety of knowing that whatever
happened in rapture won't happen again she sadly
hasn't gotten very far in her research as there is
still a ton of variables that require calculation
which is why she wants the thinker as she believes
it could solve her problem instantly this is why
she works with porter as they both want the
thinker to survive so they can use it for good
on the surface this is a much better introduction
and now provides the reason as to why we're tasked
with finding the device in the first place is we
can now change the world with the thinker the only
problem is we don't know who we are however that
will be explained a bit later sadly though after
this there isn't much in terms of a present day
story the main game suffers the same problem where
it's really just one objective that you need
to complete like finding eleanor which takes
the entire game however bioshock 2 splits up
this objective by forcing you to interact with
new people and even make some decisions except
minervas then doesn't do that from the start to
the end the main objective is to stop reid and
find the thinker there are no other characters
present in this dlc besides reid porter tenenbaum
and sigma you don't make any choices and there is
only one ending so it's really just a long string
of tedious objectives that are broken up by more
combat i said the same thing in bioshock 1 when
talking about the arcadia and market levels taking
into account the gameplay the exploration and the
story these levels flow really well and are fun to
have combat encounters in but when just looking
at the story itself it suffers there just really
isn't anything going on it's like the dlc has
a heavy focus of story in the beginning and the
end of the playthrough while the combat takes up
the middle thankfully the audio logs do break up
some of the pace and allow for more story to creep
in but all this is story from the past i'm talking
about things that are happening in the here and
now like once again how we learn about the three
characters in the main story then choose to spare
or kill them or when we finally meet eleanor but
then sofia stops us by breaking our bond together
these are things that are happening in the present
and are shaping the story the dlc does not have
any of that the first level of the game is about
going from one area to the next grabbing items
so you can open up new areas until you finally
complete the whole level this continues all the
way up to the final few minutes of the game as all
we're really trying to do is just make it to the
core of the central computing wing so we can find
the thinker throughout the whole time in this dlc
most of our interactions with these people is just
porter giving us instructions and reid projecting
a very cocky attitude because he believes that the
thinker can stop us since it can predict any
outcome except later we discover that isn't
entirely true it is calculating what we'll do but
according to the equation once we reach the core
it just stops this worries him as the outcome is
undetermined something pretty much impossible to
happen to the thinker this problem of his happens
around the time we enter his office and it's where
we discover that because of this beef reid took
it upon himself to frame porter for a crime he
didn't commit and have him thrown in jail since
he was in jail the thinker would be his to control
and now he could use it for whatever he wants but
the thinker never chose reid as much as he thinks
this to be the case in fact i don't think it
really chose anyone however it did assist porter
well thinker ryan secret police are on their way
they cooked up some kind of evidence against me
treason they say i've heard what happens to
folks who get disappeared come back as one
of those metal daddies so i'm leaving you
with something to cogitate on in my absence
inputting rapture departure protocol figure a
way to get yourself out of this city thinker
you've got to live on no matter what happens to
me so before being shipped off to prison porter
created a program so that the thinker could escape
reed's grasp this makes sense as when we enter the
last few minutes of the game reed discovers
that the thinker wasn't working with him but
against him it's also around this time where reid
expresses his confusion as to how porter walked
out of persephone unscathed and an idea came into
my head and for the very first time in this series
i finally predicted something because we discover
that subject sigma is charles milton porter going
back to that rapture departure protocol the
thinker determined that the best possible way
for him to escape was to enlist the help of porter
himself to get sigma to follow the thinker he used
the personality duplication program which is what
porter designed when he tried to replicate his
wife but the thinker instead replicated porter's
own mind besides being a bit of an obvious twist i
was happy that i did manage to guess this and the
plot twisted in general was really nice as it does
solve the question of why sigma is even following
orders to begin with i'm just really glad that
they cleared up that question by still continuing
to use the bioshock formula of a weird plot twist
that ties the whole story together after this
revelation we get to explore porter's office
and find an audio recording of his time with ai
pearl i believe i'm done feeding audio recordings
and personal anecdotes to the thinker i am set
to test the personality duplication function
target personality pearl porter thinker are
you ready, yes milton starting test hello pearl
how have you been just wonderful milton i've
missed you though it's been so long pearl i no
no this isn't right it isn't her thinker
stop the test but what's the matter milton
don't you still love me oh god oh god i said
i said end function thinker now it's over
i'll admit i've seen this exact situation tons
of time in other media and this usually ends
with the person dedicated to the machine
and desperately wanting their significant
other back porter though immediately recognized
the problems with doing something like this so
good job on porter for breaking the mold a
bit and not succumbing to your own creation
on a more serious note this technology while
impressive does have some adverse effects on
the user as we heard with porter as great as this
technology is the duplication program should not
be used ever again and i think porter agrees as
we go further down the lower halls of the office
we can see a memorial for pearl meaning he still
hasn't been able to move on from the incident and
honestly who can really blame him at the very
bottom though is a bathysphere and inside is
tenenbaum with the thinker in good hands and the
two safe from harm tenenbaum plans to find the
cure for adam so she could change porter back to
who he once was after that is finished she'll then
look into all the others back in rapture but we
don't know what exactly happens we do see parts
of the suit on the ground and someone standing by
a grave which we can assume is porter meaning that
he was able to become a human again overall we get
a very happy ending the cure for adam is complete
meaning the residents of rapture can eventually
return to being normal again adam and plasmids
can now be used by the general public in a safe
and secure manner and porter was able to move on
and say goodbye to his wife is a nice conclusion
to the game and also a nice conclusion to therapture story
bioshock infinite is a pretty
good game there's a lot that it does well but
there's also a lot that it does wrong it's got a
fantastic story with a wonderful dynamic between
its two main characters but it also has a severe
lack of interesting world building and an awful
dlc that was ultimately unnecessary so without
further ado let's get started so where else
would we start then at the intro this is the most
important part of a game's story but this is taken
to the extreme with bioshock as these intros are
made to intrigue the player enough to keep going
you may find this confusing as i literally just
described an intro was meant to do but think back
on the previous games for a moment bioshock 1
story was a bit confusing as all of a sudden we
arrive at rapture and are helping the first guy we
meet without even a chance to question why we're
doing this in the first place bioshock 1 obviously
clears this up at the end of the game in one of
the best ways i've ever seen but i can almost
guarantee that the setting and combat of bioshock1
carried you throughout the game rather than
the story of just killing the big bad guy well
bioshock infinite does the same thing its story
is hidden and never mentioned until the very end
because the devs know this they need to intrigue
the player enough in other ways to keep them going
like the aforementioned setting and gameplay
this is why it builds off the original game's
unique introduction bioshock infinite starts in
1912 with the player on a boat being taken to a
lighthouse for context since this game is in 1912
that means we are 48 years before bioshock 1 even
occurs that means all the previous games and their
events had never happened yet rapture wasn't built
hell i don't even think ryan was born yet we also
get to see our character's face hear their voice
and know their name all within about two minutes
which is a lot faster than the previous games our
protagonist name is booker dewitt who was brought
here to do a job booker is then given a box with a
few items such as a pistol a code a picture of our
target among other items the picture of the girl
has a note on the back that says bring the girl
to new york unharmed so we can assume that we're
here to find this person on the card the people
taking us to the location are unknown as they're
only referred to as man and lady however the way
they talk is odd almost as if they're watching
us from a distance they don't talk to booker and
if he doesn't climb the ladder they'll say this
he's not moving he will eventually i suppose he
does it's like they think they're invisible or
analyzing some experiment like some scientists
would do it just feels off as we approach the
lighthouse we get more information on the task
at hand as the note reads bring us the girl and
wipe away the debt once again we can assume that
booker has some debts that need to be paid and
it's because of these threats that he took this
job in the first place everything initially looks
pretty normal until we see someone dead and tied
up with a sign that reads don't disappoint us
it continues to get even weirder as when we
finally get to the top of the lighthouse we
input the code and the sky turns red momentarily
as a horn blares every time the color changes
a chair appears and seeing as we're at the
top without anywhere else to go we take a seat
words cannot describe the beauty of columbia it's
truly a magnificent place but after we arrive we
see a lot of religious symbolism and are told that
to enter columbia we have to be reborn anew via
baptism we accept and are able to explore columbia
to our hearts content but we have to remember that
we're in uncharted territory and have to blend in
except that may not be as easy as it sounds as we
discover that the false shepard is prophesied to
enter columbia with a defining mark of an a.d on
their hand the same one that booker has we enter
the city's raffle win and are given the reward
of pelting a couple with a baseball until our
identity is revealed and are forced to fight i
know i sped through that so allow me to explain
why bioshock infident on its own has a pretty
fantastic intro arguably the best in the series
but it reaches unprecedented levels of quality
when you take into account bioshock 1. columbia
and even bioshock infinite are the antithesis
of rapture and bioshock 1. not just in the setting
of the two games but the values of each setting
and the actual sequence of events that occur
in the game's intros it's clear from the first
moment of the game that the developers took heavy
inspiration from the original the reason being
that irrational games the devs behind bioshock
1 also made infinite whereas 2k games irrational
games publisher made bioshock 2. that's not only
why bioshock 2 feels so different from the other
games but why these two feel so similar bioshock 1
starts on a plane that crashes in the ocean we're
then taken to a lighthouse which then leads to
rapture we start in the sky and end in the sea
with the lighthouse being the mediator between
these two parts of the world whereas bioshock
impedance starts in the sea and ends in the sky
with the lighthouse being the mediator again
one game's start is the other game's end our
first encounter with rapture is quite dark as
the first person we see gets his guts spilled on
the floor by a splicer from the moment we enter
rapture we are thrown into the deep end however
as you play you start to appreciate rapture more
and it's almost like a home away from home minus
the splicers of course raptor's a really relaxing
place and the thought of what this looked like
in its prime gives you that sort of warm and
welcoming feeling whereas columbia does not our
first interaction with columbia is the opposite
of dark we're welcomed by many religious people
before walking the streets of the city where the
citizens of columbia will be having wonderful
conversations about the city and will even
greet and compliment booker you get that warm
feeling that rapture provides later in the game
at the very start but that warm feeling goes
away eventually as you uncover columbia's true
backstory furthermore each city's ideologies
couldn't be farther from one another rapture's
tagline is no gods or kings only men on top of
this religion while accepted is not publicly
shown as andrew ryan didn't want any public
institutions related to religion within rapture
this is why we see the bible amongst the cargo
and smugglers hideout in colombia religion is the
basis for its creation where the people of the
city worship father comstock who is the leader
of the founders a group and religion based on
many traditional religious and patriotic values
we're also immediately greeted by religious quotes
and bible verses while descending into columbia
upon stepping out we see a stained glass painting
depicting father comstock bringing the people to
columbia and there's also tons of other statues
showing the city and father comstock's glory i'm
not a religious person so i can't say with
complete certainty but i'm convinced that
majority of these depictions of father comstock
are literally ripped from famous artwork related
to jesus and the bible because while i can't
put my finger on what exactly it's referencing
these paintings feel oddly familiar to me as
if i'd seen them before in a different context
we are then shown this massive room filled with
candles and water that is used for prayer and
baptisms once we awaken columbia we can see the
statues of the founding fathers who are also
revered as religious or at least prominent figures
within colombia so we have a king in the form of
father comstock who worships a higher being quite
different than what andrew ryan believed in ryan
believed in objectivism a belief based on the
individual and due to rapture's location and
values it allowed those involved to succeed
on an individual level this even extends to
the gameplay as while some splicers work together
not everyone is aligned with one another everyone
seems to be acting out of pure self-interest
in colombia its citizens work together for
the benefit of the city and the father they're
acting as a group rather than individuals sort of
like the family from bioshock too but by far its
most staggering difference is in its inclusivity
ryan and rapture didn't really care about the
inner workings of a person as long as that
person had the drive to seek something greater
in their life in rapture there is a prominent
picture called the rapture's best and brightest
and within this picture are both men and women
those women also being tenenbaum and sofia lamb
arguably the two most important women in rapture
there's also dr suchong who is of asian ethnicity
and while not in the picture there's also charles
milton porter owner of the thinker and he's
african-american rapture is also very accepting in
regards to sexual orientation as sander cohen one
of rapture's best and brightest is gay given the
time frame of the game it's possible people have
their own opinions on someone's sex and race but
at the very least they're welcomed into rapture
and not rejected for their differences this is
in stark contrast to colombia where most of its
regular residents are white in fact the first
black person we see is tied to a post because
this couple is in an interracial relationship
since columbia is ruled by one man and not ruled
by the city's basis of creation that person's
ideologies are the golden rule of the city and
father comstock is a white supremacist who is
extremely racist against anyone who isn't
white and refuses to condemn organizations
that believe in this ideology a good example is
the order of the ravens in colombia who believe
in racial purity this is reinforced by the fact
that they are not only dressed as kkk members but
have paintings and statues that depict abraham
lincoln as the devil and john wilkes booth his
assassin as a hero within the organization we
can also see a chinese prisoner being tortured
and killed via ravens and to top it all off
we see a statue outside of the building of
comstock defeating a multi-headed serpent
however this serpent has the heads of three
men who are black chinese and jewish all with
exaggerated features like big noses and lips
as for things such as gender or sexual orientation
it's not outright said but there is definitely
some hints that columbia's values fit with ones
from the current time period there's a severe
lack of lgbt representation in this game with the
only ones i could find being the rare case a guy
hits on booker furthermore women at least those
within authority or power seem to be tolerated
rather than celebrated there's a kinetoscope
of rosalind lutes who is a quantum physicist
and the sole reason columbia can even float to
begin with but in this film at the end there's a
question that says how does that darn thing fly to
which she responds it's quantum mechanics but at
the bottom it reads we say it's more like women's
intuition however there is clearly women in power
like daisy fitzroy so while this doesn't outright
prove that all women aren't viewed the same as men
at the very least it shows how much people
downplayed lutes's creation of columbia and
her intelligence and seeing if she's easily one of
the most important women and the most intelligent
person in columbia i can't imagine how a regular
woman would be seen within the eyes of men besides
all the symbolism and ideologies regarding
colombia the actual interactions within the
intro are extremely fun before taking part in the
raffle we can explore the carnival area where we
can take part in carnival games involving weapons
and vigors which acts as a sort of hidden tutorial
we also see these weird interactions most notably
the statue of rosalind lutes changing to who we'll
discover is robert lutes this telegram being given
to booker that says not to pick number 77 which
happens to be the ball we choose at the raffle and
then the final one where the lieutenants make us
play heads and tails and not only does heads
win every time but it's won a lot all of them
are nice touches and subtle hints regarding the
game's actual plot bioshock 1 and infinite are the
complete opposite of one another and it's by far
the best dichotomy i've seen in the game to date
bioshock 2 build off the world of the first game
but decided to change the ideology of rapture
to show how the other end of the spectrum could
operate in the same city but infinite took this
idea and ran with it by not only creating a city
completely opposite to rapture in just about every
way but also took specific moments and cutscenes
from the first game and made those opposite when
compared together it's genius game design genius
storytelling and overall gives bioshock impedance
the best intro in the series getting back
on track we just turned a guard's brains to
mush and are now fighting the columbian police
while trying to find the girl we came here for
within this section is the aforementioned
order of ravens but there also seems to be
a secret home a little farther down for people
who actually praise abraham lincoln there isn't
much here but it is nice to see that some of
the residents don't all share the same values
after multiple battles with the city's police were
briefly stopped by comstock himself who claims to
not only know who booker is but all of his past
sins including wounded knee the pinkertons his
gambling and alcohol addiction and someone named
anna this made the situation a bit more tense as
now we aren't operating away from the watchful
eye of comstock as he not only knows who booker
is but why he is here it makes the player question
who this comstock really is and how he's related
to booker furthermore it also forces the player
to question what booker did we then make it to
monument island the place where this girl should
be located and it's clear here that the game is
trying to set up the typical girl trapped in the
tower trope but the way this was presented in
the game is really well done as once again these
chilling feelings of the story continue to grow
all throughout the area are caution signs and a
plethora of equipment and wires that make it feel
like a laboratory rather than a home it's a lot
different than what one would expect as you would
think this girl is either relaxing in some random
house or at a very top of a luxurious tower and
while the latter is technically true large rich
towers don't usually come equipped with caution
signs and chalkboards full of data it continues
to get even weirder as we see photography rooms
filled with pictures of her and rooms that seem
to be made for testing an experiment most likely
involving her there's even a projector that has
some film of this girl doing specific tasks like
dancing painting and lock picking we then get
to see how the operation was created as there
is two-way mirrors in these rooms allowing them to
spy on her without her knowing we also get to see
her open a portal to another world before closing
it momentarily it's given just the right amount of
time to confuse the player on what the hell just
happened without it being overly long and also
calls back to the rest of the tower now it makes
sense why they were testing and observing her she
clearly has these superpowers booker tries to find
his way around the rooms but falls through the
ceiling which rightfully startles her this girl
is elizabeth and she is one of the most intricate
characters in the entire series she is shocked
by booker's arrival in the tower and attacks
him until she realizes this is the moment she's
been waiting for she can now finally escape this
tower that she has been stuck in since she was a
child so elizabeth and booker escaped the tower
together until elizabeth's mechanical bodyguard
songbird shows up and attempts to stop booker the
bird almost succeeds but booker despite falling an
incredibly far distance is able to live thanks to
falling into one of columbia's beaches so what's
really going on here well elizabeth has the unique
ability to open tears these tears are essentially
ripples in time that allow the person viewing the
terror to see into an alternate dimension this is
why we can hear the song fortunate sun through one
of the tears later in the game despite that
song not being created for another 40 years
these tears aren't unique to the individual as we
see more kinetoscopes of people talking about the
tares so everyone can view them but not everyone
can create them the two most notable characters
that can create these terrors is elizabeth and
luteces rosalind before columbia was experimenting
with adams and found a way to indefinitely suspend
atoms in mid-air this led to the aptly named blue
test field discovery comstock would eventually
meet with luteces through some way and through
their collaboration would create columbia using
her lutece field as thanks for helping create the
floating city comstock promised that she could
continue her experimentation and it was during
these experiments that she met robert despite what
the game will initially tell you robert is not the
twin of rosalind he is rosalind in an alternate
world rosalind was born a man named robert
these two are the same person just in different
timelines as for elizabeth she was able to create
terrors from a very early age it's not explained
why just yet but it will be towards the end of the
game whereas luteces is able to create one through
science and experimentation elizabeth can just
create one when she wants she also mentions that
when she was younger she was able to create new
worlds with these tears but now she isn't able
to as often this is most likely due to the siphon
equipment in the tower as it's literally siphoning
her powers away i don't think it's necessarily
removing it altogether but more like storing it as
when we get to the end of the game she is way more
powerful implying that we were able to give them
back to her speaking of elizabeth after we regain
our footing on the beach we go to find her and
try to get her out of the city but it seems that
comstock and his forces have already caught on to
our location this is also elizabeth's first time
experiencing combat and i really like how they
didn't just have her deal with it as right at
the moment the shooting starts she runs away and
we have to chase her down the reason she ran is
because elizabeth thinks booker is a killer and
given how many people we just killed she's not
entirely wrong i like that irrational games took
into consideration how elizabeth would feel after
seeing someone die as it's not something you can
simply brush off this also extends to the numerous
other things elizabeth does like cover her ears
during this scene when the noise gets too loud or
just interacting with the environment like when
she asks for cotton candy it's incredibly small
but it heightens the experience of the game i find
myself always looking at elizabeth waiting to see
where she'll go next or what she'll say since her
input was always interesting to hear this also
extends to her relationship with booker bioshock
2 had this father-daughter style dynamic as well
with delta and eleanor but what i really think
makes infinite better in this regard is because
we actually get to spend time with elizabeth
obviously the reason why we can't see eleanor is
due to the plot but still elizabeth acts like this
little girl who has seen the world for the first
time and booker becomes this father figure making
sure she doesn't run off and get into danger and
i really love the dynamic they have after some
time booker and elizabeth will come across lady
comstock's airship as they plan to use that as
their means of escape but it's blocked and can
only be accessed by using the shock jockey vigor
this then leads to duo to cornelius slate who has
a really interesting section as it forces booker
to confront his past slate and booker knew each
other before the events of the game as they were
at wounded knee together after this booker would
reflect on his life and his actions while slate
would meet and join father comstock who would then
lead them to the boxer rebellion both of these
events were gruesome and tragic times for booker
so having him relive his past while also having
elizabeth discover his past was an intense moment
we the player figured this out alongside elizabeth
and after this encounter you start to view booker
as a completely different person for better or for
worse both wounded knee and the boxer rebellion
were also real world events that happened which
made learning about these all the more interesting
wounded knee was an awful massacre that saw an
army of united states soldiers kill over 300
native americans during this massacre booker
was accused by a sergeant that he had native
american blood in him to avoid the backlash and
repercussions that would come from this booker
decided to prove to his fellow men that he was
indeed a true soldier of america by scalping
many native americans and then burning dozens of
teepees wounded knee is not only an incredible
part of the story as it defines booker's character
but it's more important for us the player as we
get to see who booker really is and are given the
option to form her own opinion about him that will
continue to stay throughout the whole game for
the bioshock series this was a nice twist as we
went from having two samaritans who got caught
up in terrible circumstances to a protagonist
who was a mass murderer it's a unique idea for
the series and one that i welcomed as for the
other tragic event in history the boxer rebellion
was a war that started because a group of chinese
anti-christians called the boxers were killing
and massacring christian missionaries churches
and parishioners throughout all of northern china
in real life this led to the creation of the eight
nation alliance which included countries like
the british empire the united states russia
japan and many others all of whom were against
the boxers as for bioshock infinite it's unclear
whether columbia fought them alone or joined the
eight nation alliance but given why this rebellion
started it's obvious columbia wanted some
revenge even if it didn't directly involve them
these events were a part of comstock's history
which means it was also part of columbia's history
which is why there's an exhibit of the events
in the hall of heroes however slate doesn't like
the exhibit as it claims that comstock was not
only at the battle of wounded knee but was the
hero of the boxer rebellion he's technically
wrong but he's technically right but we'll get
to that later after the exhibit we can make it
to the main attraction which is another exhibit
related to lady comstock here is where we also
get to learn about the vox populi since entering
colombia we have heard a few rumors about them and
this is no different according to the exhibit we
learned that not only is elizabeth the daughter
of comstock but lady comstock was also murdered
by her servant daisy fitzroy who would eventually
become the leader of the vox populi a rebellious
organization looking to put an end to the current
rule of columbia and take it for their own many of
its members are irish and african-american two
groups of people who are notably discriminated
against within columbia once again this is another
great moment for the story as we not only got some
key information but elizabeth is now learning
her own backstory alongside us and the revelation
that the man who had locked her up in the tower
was her father is a terrifying feeling for her
the seed of the prophet shall sit the throne
and drown in flame the mountains of man
you're comstock's daughter no i can't be i i can't
he wants you to follow his footsteps well i want a
puppy but that doesn't mean i'm gonna get one the
beginning of that speech is also pretty important
as comstock says the seat of the prophet shall sit
the throne and drown in flame the mountains of man
remember this for later once all the exhibits are
done we can confront slate so we can get our shock
jockey and it's here where it's probably a good
time to mention this game's combat infinite's
combat bothers me quite a lot bioshock 1 and 2
had the uniqueness of the splicers who not only
had some decent personality via combat dialogue
but also looked unique and were just overall a
blast to fight against i don't feel the same way
when i play infinite maybe it's because i like the
older game's health system or that those games had
different ammo types with actual unique weapons or
the beauty of the plasmids but something always
feels off every time i play one other issue is
that theme of morality there is none of that in
this game and for a series that is stuck with
it for two straight games it's a shame to see it
disappear in this title this may have something to
do with how the narrative is structured and how
we're given the illusion of choice but bioshock
1 and 2 did the same thing and managed to give us
multiple endings to this story and also feel like
our choices had some amount of weight to it this
also extends to the larger enemies in the game
whereas in bioshock 1 deciding to fight the big
daddies was an impossible feat you were supposed
to view this as a difficult battle but assuming
you were skilled enough to prevail you were given
an immense amount of gear and atom to use infinite
doesn't have this as there's no decisions that
hold any weight you just simply go from objective
to objective fighting people along the way without
a care in the world and while the game isn't that
long it does get quite boring when you just want
to learn the story but are stuck fighting a bunch
of enemies because elizabeth can't pick the lock
needed to progress even the original games fell
into this trap sometimes but they still managed
to add something to the combat like sander cohen's
art exhibit which is really just a ton of combat
back to back but with the added distinctiveness
of the enemies themselves and the fact that we
had to take pictures of their corpses so that
we can display them it added a bit of variety it
wasn't much variety but at least made the combat
a bit more engaging the combat in infinite is very
actiony and streamlined you aren't really fighting
for resources or upgrades as elizabeth more often
than not will keep you stocked when needed there's
no health kits the player can have in stock and
the shield also regenerates given these additions
and literally just how the combat arenas work in
this game it's clear that irrational games went
for a more action-adventure title rather than
one that had immersive sim or survival elements
it's practically a railroaded shooter without
any variety this lack of variety also extends to
the levels themselves if i'm being honest infinite
may have some of the worst levels in the series
columbia itself is gorgeous just like rapture
but throughout the game we were able to see
different areas all with different backstories
i can name quite a few of the levels in the past
games but i can barely remember the names of a
couple locations in columbia and the only ones
i do remember were only because of one scene in
the level that either i hated or i loved other
than the actual beauty creativity and the lore
that the level brings into the world bioshock 1
had levels like hephaestus medical pavilion ford
frolic arcadia and so many more that serve some
purpose ford frolic was the entertainment center
run by sander cohen and arcadia was a botanical
garden that also helps supply rapture's oxygen
infinite levels don't take from what bioshock
once started there is rarely any levels that
actually attempt to show that colombia is more
than just a few areas made by some developers
there's no levels that showcase how the quantum
particles can suspend the city in the air
how the people of the city can even breed this
high up considering at the very least oxygen would
not be plentiful at 15 000 feet or even where the
energy comes from to even power this city emporia
a late-game area which is known to be a place in
columbia for the ultra rich looks no different
than the welcoming center in the beginning of the
game thankfully it's not all bad as shantytown is
a really good level that does highlight a lot
of differences between the others but that's
only a couple levels out of the total of 16.
all of these problems make it quite difficult
to play again and yes this is more of a critique
of the gameplay rather than the story which is the
opposite of the intended purpose for this video
but we have discussed in the previous games how
its gameplay was intertwined with the narrative
thanks to the themes of morality with the little
sisters and how we're in this unknown location
so by making the game more survival focused it
tied the game's combat to its story infinite just
feels like a playground adventure where we go on
zip lines and mow down dozens of enemies without
at all considering that we're literally in the
same situation as delta and jack we are lost in an
unknown city and have to struggle to survive but
infinite fails to convey this early we talked about
the vox populi and it's after the fight with slate
where we get to learn more about them elizabeth
during our journey says how she wants to escape
and go to paris but as we remember booker has a
job to do and that means we go to new york so when
he takes control of the first lady's airship he
sets the destination to new york elizabeth catches
onto this and gets a bit emotional honestly i
was going to mention how awful her crying is but
it does make sense as she is faking it so that
booker drops his guard so she can knock him out
elizabeth disappears right after this as she
was about to depart but the vox populi show up
booker then meets with daisy and they come to an
agreement if booker gets daisy the guns needed
for the army then she'll give him the airship
back where they drop us off though is finton a
place owned by jeremiah fink the one we saw in
the intro even though this is the first time we
are without elizabeth it doesn't last that long as
we'll eventually catch up to her and while we do
repair the relationship it's not back to what it
was before as elizabeth is a bit more cynical and
only joins him because he's the only way she'll
get to paris she sees booker as a means to an end
similar to how booker viewed elizabeth in the
beginning we're only halfway through the game
and already the relationship has taken so many
different turns and it's only going to continue
as we progress and i must say it's really well
done as i said we're now in finkon and this is
one of those locations where i only remember it
because of one scene
i don't really have much to add here i think the
scene speaks for itself people are so desperate
enough for jobs that they're willing to fight
others to get it what they're auctioning here by
the way is their time saying that they can get
the job done faster than anyone else the first
auction that occurred was for someone to haul
a half a ton of coal from fink manufacturing
to shantytown and the guy who won believed
he could do it in 5 minutes and 50 seconds
it's unclear what happens but i can only assume
if they fail they probably don't get paid for the
job or unable to work other jobs due to the lack
of work ethic in the eyes of the company besides
being the location of some of the worst conditions
in columbia it's also here where the story goes
off the rails i briefly talked about the tears
and how they are portals to other dimensions
and all of that is shown here we make it to the
gunsmith location and discover that he's gone
however his wife is still here and says that they
took him and locked him up we end up finding where
he's located and also find out that he was being
tortured for information but when we arrive in his
cell we discover that he's dead the luteces
show up again and in a cryptic way explain
that while we see mr lin as dead he can also be
seen as alive it's just a matter of perspective
that's when a tear appears and shows that mr lin
was never killed in another universe meaning we
can still get the guns to daisy of course in this
version of colombia mr lin is alive but that's not
the only thing that's changed the police we killed
earlier are now alive again but something's wrong
they're alive but they're dead they are alive but
they remember being dead so they're going insane
this sort of situation happens a few times with
booker where he starts bleeding out of nowhere
the reason he's bleeding is because his mind is
taking his current memories and combining it with
new memories and it's causing this nauseous
effect in his mind and causing him to bleed
they are alive in this world but they remember
their other selves in a previous timeline dying
thanks to these new memories suddenly appearing
in their minds when booker enters this new
columbia adding on to more changes we see that
mr lin is alive but is going a bit insane but
more importantly his wife is white now and now a
devoted follower of father comstock as opposed to
the original version who was asian and praying to
buddha we learned from his wife that the weapons
he made are in shantytown which is our next stop
shantytown is a pretty good level as we get to
see how the lower class of columbia live there
are signs everywhere asking people for food or
for a doctor and the bar down the street even
has a corpse in it and judging from the knife
and the blood on the table i think we know why as
usual we're going to need to push through lots of
guards to make it to our objective but once we
arrive we hit another roadblock while in this
columbia mr lin is alive the tools are chained
up and extremely heavy however there's another
tear showing that these tools aren't there meaning
they're already back at the shop so we go through
another tear into another columbia but once
again this isn't the only thing that has changed
bring us the girl and wipe away the debt as plans
go i'd seen worse except this girl was already
gone monument island's a damn ghost town it seems
like they evacuated her when they heard i was here
an old friend told me comstock spirited her off
to that fortress of his as a one-man job this
just went from betting on the river to drawing
dead so it seems that elizabeth has been taken
from monument island and since booker couldn't
find her it seemed like he joined the vox as a
way to take down comstock however judging from the
posters it seems like he died and has now become a
martyr for the vox i also realized that we're
30 minutes into this video and i haven't even
mentioned the box of phones yet bioshock infinite
like its predecessors has audio logs in the form
of voxophones but unlike the other games i think
infident really lacks in this department as well
some of the audio logs are quite nice as they do
provide a decent amount of story like some of the
ones from booker's past or most of daisy fitzroy's
but many of them just seem to exist without real
substance i think 60% of them is just speeches from
lady comstock and father comstock about some stuff
that really doesn't matter there is a nice set of
logs from a hattie gerst very reminiscent of mark
meltzer that talks about her husband and how he
came down with an illness but since there wasn't
much that could be done he decided to become one
of the handymen in hopes of having a chance at
life but ultimately it would eventually perish
at the hands of the vox when he went to work
for the founders as i said there's some pretty
decent story within these logs i just feel like
the previous games did it a whole lot better
getting back on track we're still in shantytown
in this new columbia but booker starts bleeding
again since the memories of his current self and
his other cell from this universe are blending
together in this columbia the vox not only have
a foothold in shantytown but also in finton as
there are vox forces everywhere but every action
has its consequences in this world while the
weapons and tools were brought to the vox mr
lin and his wife are dead elizabeth is upset at
this revelation as while there probably wasn't
much they could have done to prevent this outcome
it's still something she hadn't considered that
across multiple timelines and universes people can
be dead and alive at any time on a more positive
note though we did get daisy her gun so we can
get the airship back at least that's what booker
believes because that deal was made with the first
columbia's daisy fitzroy there's no way to be sure
that this daisy made the same deal i'm not sure
if this is to showcase how confused booker has
gotten after jumping through two different worlds
or a lack of polish when it comes to this game's
writing after joining the vox and pushing back the
founders daisy calls us and our cover's been blown
daisy believes that we're an imposter of the real
book or dewitt so she has the vox attack us once
we battle through some of the vox we meet daisy in
just at the perfect time to see her kill think and
while cool i gotta ask what was with this blood
wiping thing i'm not even going to talk about
the risk of infection that could happen from this
but what was the point was it to show that she's
somehow crazy or that she's badass that she'll
kill someone and wipe their blood on her face
i don't know it just felt really unnecessary once
again after more fighting we can finally confront
her but she has a child held hostage and the only
way to stop her is to have elizabeth sneak in and
kill her just like the many interactions
we've seen before this makes total sense
anyone would be in a state of disarray after
taking someone's life especially someone like
her who's a very caring person this decision
however changes elizabeth she becomes a woman
now instead of just a girl this is symbolized
in her cutting her hair and also changing her
outfit and demeanor you may be confused as to how
this is supposed to make her a woman but the dlc
will explain this but we have the airship and can
now escape to colombia except nothing's ever easy
this highlights a glaring issue with this game and
that's the constant backtracking and cliffhanging
when it comes to completing objectives the other
two games did this as well but they weren't as
bad as infinite to give you a refresher we got
the objective to reach the first lady's airship
when we landed on the beach but we were then
blocked by the rail system and needed some shock
jockey so we started backtracking after getting
the shock jockey elizabeth knocks us out since
booker was going to take her to new york instead
so now we have to join daisy and get the vox their
guns for their war once again more backtracking
that's also not even getting into the multiple
times we have to go through finkton because mr
lin is dead in one world then alive in another
but the tools aren't here but they're in another
so we go back and forth between the same area at
least three different times and then finally after
all these objectives are completed totaling about
four hours of playtime songbird comes back and
wrecks the airship i can't decide whether or
not i'd actually be more upset if we just simply
lost the airship again and had to find it a third
time rather than seeing four hours of work get
destroyed in a matter of seconds but either option
would definitely not be preferable you literally
spend a third of this game probably more than that
doing this one objective but the game attempts to
disguise it by giving you small tasks along the
way i would argue this is just as bad as rescuing
atlas's family which took just as long all for
that to fail as well but not only was this faked
and shows the depths that fontaine was going to
go to succeed but there was actual emotion behind
this scene it goes from an action-packed race as
we try to save the family before they're killed
by splicers to immediately shifting into a somber
more emotional track of music with this calming
aftermath we were too late and atlas couldn't save
his family and he pours his heart out during this
scene and emotionally resonates with the player
as not only does atlas want to kill ryan we do
as well booker and elizabeth just move right
along completely ignoring the fact that the one
thing they've spent hours trying to find is gone
no emotion no break in the action just another
scene with the luteces it's utterly surreal how i
was the only one who was emotionally torn because
of this yet none of the characters seem to agree
this probably wouldn't be half as bad if this
tragedy wasn't followed up by probably one of
the worst levels in the entire game emporia
is awful and literally because of one enemy
lady comstock admittedly from a story perspective
it's pretty good as we learned that father
comstock was sterile due to the multiple tests he
had done with the tares meaning elizabeth isn't
related to father comstock and then we also
discovered that lady comstock never actually
liked elizabeth and saw her as an illegitimate
child to which she would eventually attempt to
blackmail father comstock by claiming to tell all
of columbia that elizabeth isn't his daughter he
would then take it upon himself to kill her for
saying this but her servant daisy had walked in
during the killing forcing comstock to pin the
blame on her which of course explains how daisy
became the leader of the vox on top of this we
also learned that the lutesis were killed by fink
who was ordered by father comstock to carry out
the hit it is some genuinely incredible backstory
and it's story i've been waiting to hear it's just
a shame it's surrounded by this level i can't be
100 certain on this claim but i do hope that many
can agree that lady comstock's boss fight is just
bad both narratively and mechanically the series
has always struggled with boss fights and this
is no exception the whole reason we even fight her
is because elizabeth and booker are once again hit
with another roadblock which is a door that will
only open for lady comstock and even though she
has been dead for some time she's been locked in
an airtight coffin to preserve her body but when
we open it she becomes a ghost and raises the
dead to fight us this is truly where the game
went off the rails it felt so far-fetched to me
that i was genuinely confused on how this was even
possible the real reason the ghost is even
an entity to begin with is because it's a
combination of both elizabeth's feeling towards
her and lady comstock's body that's why she
acts angrily towards us just as elizabeth felt
angry at lady comstock for not being her mother
the two end up forgiving each other though for
the pain they cause one another which ultimately
allows us to get into comstock's house and
lady comstock herself gets to rest in peace
i understand bioshock is a series where we have
magic and cities that are located in uninhabitable
environments but i don't recall the series ever
going this far with its science fiction elements
the only other time we saw ghosts in this game
was back in rapture but these were cleared up by
the story in a fairly believable way which was
due to adam not only altering people's genetic
code but by also constantly being recycled thanks
to the little sisters it caused certain memories
of other people to be shown in the form of ghostly
apparitions was it a bit much maybe a little but
there was at least a valiant attempt to try to
explain the phenomenon and also ground it into
the world this game's version of ghosts is just
the complete opposite she's also an absolute bullet
sponge and while i didn't mind it the first time
my mood got progressively worse after the second
and third time we fight her the same exact way
after finally being led inside we're stopped
once again by resident roadblock but this time
songbird actually succeeds and manages to take
elizabeth away from us booker manages to just
barely survive but as he attempts to chase her
down he stops momentarily as he notices that
snow is on the ground despite it being july
booker has been pulled into yet another version
of columbia these screams of elizabeth that we
hear in game are not actually happening in the
current columbia as he discovers that they're
from a tear this tear is the previous columbia
we are just in implying he's now somewhere else
this columbia is what would happen
if comstock fulfilled his prophecy
i told you earlier to remember that quote
the drowning flames the mountain of man
this is why this world of columbia is one where
comstock passes away and elizabeth has become his
successor at the end of his prophecy is columbia
fighting against the united states we see a much
older elizabeth as well in this world and it's
discovered that she brought us here into this
world to show us what could happen if comstock
wins she then gives us a note for elizabeth but
doesn't tell us what it means as is for her eyes
only old lady elizabeth then sends us back into
columbia and we're just in time as we can see that
they are in the process of extracting elizabeth's
power knowing what can happen if they succeed we
put a stop to it and rescue elizabeth we're now
just a few steps away from reaching comstock
all we have to do is just get aboard his ship
and if you weren't convinced that infinite was a
playground adventure game with cool explosions and
high octane combat then this surely should have
convinced you booker as a one-man army charges
towards the airship killing dozens of soldiers
along the way he also has to defend the airship
by himself with the occasional help of songbird as
an ending battle it's heroic tough and really cool
as an ending for bioshock it's absurd i've already
explained in detail my issues about this game's
new combat style as it doesn't fit with the themes
of bioshock and this fight was a big reason why
seeing as we finally made it to the ending we can
now understand the story except we aren't there
just yet bioshock infinite really likes to hold
the plot twist until the very last minute in the
airship is the prophet himself comstock doesn't
tell us anything and instead wants dewitt to tell
elizabeth the real truth even though he has no
idea what's going on due to his ignorance he
takes this opportunity to drown comstock and put
an end to his reign honestly i've been waiting for
booker to be completely honest about his feelings
towards elizabeth and i'm so glad he was finally
able to do that it's clear that he cares about her
he may not have been before when he first met her
but over time this became more than just a job
for him further solidifying that the way their
relationship was written over the course of the
game was stellar and by far one of the best parts
of this game fast forwarding a bit we defend the
airship and are able to use songbird to destroy
the tower which houses the siphons that took
elizabeth's powers once those were destroyed she
regains all of them back immediately after this we
take songbird down to rapture which kills him due
to the water pressure we then take a bathysphere
to a weird world with dozens of lighthouses these
doors are like physical doors to other worlds
and with all her powers back she can see into
all of them regardless if that door is in the past
present or future she can not only see the doors
but also what's inside of them she's practically
all-knowing at this point which explains why the
ending of the game happens the way that it
does at the very end booker is taken back to
the baptism he had before the events of the game
but he refuses just like before however booker is
told by elizabeth that he didn't refuse in some
worlds and that altered things in that world it's
also revealed that because of this event booker is
also father comstock after the events of wounded
knee booker was regretful of his actions and saw
clarity through religion but that was in his world
in some worlds he also refused but in others
he agreed to the baptism those who agreed would
become father comstock if booker refused he stays
the depressed and regretful booker dewitt but if
he agreed he's reborn a new man one who is cleared
of all sins and is reborn again in the face of god
this leads him down a new holier path and a new
man needs a new name so he would then change it to
zachary hale comstock that is the true plot twist
of bioshock infinite booker has been fighting
himself the whole game but we're still not done
yet once again this game is about constants and
variables everything in booker's life was a
constant up until the baptism every single
version of booker whether they stayed booker or
became comstock all took a part in wounded knee
that's why slate was mad at comstock for claiming
to be a wounded knee when he knew he wasn't there
he was but not as comstock as this was before
the baptism once booker goes to the baptism the
world splits if booker rejects he then stays the
booker dewitt during this time booker would then
join the pinkerton detective agency where he would
garner a reputation for ending worker strikes with
severe violence it was also here where he would
meet annabelle the woman who would eventually
become his wife they would then end up having a
child anna yes i know how confusing that sounds
but this birth would end up causing more problems
for booker not only did annabelle die during the
pregnancy but due to her death he acquired a
massive gambling and drinking problem leaving
him in massive debt however robert lutes arrived
at his office one day and offered to take anna
from him which would absolve his debt that phrase
bring us the girl and wipe away the debt was not
about rescuing elizabeth it was about selling anna
to Robert so that he could be debt free right after
this happened though booker regretted his actions
and chased robert down an alley where he also
meets comstock and rosalind just as he's about to
pull her through her pinky is caught and taken off
anna is gone and it's due to this decision that
booker decided to get the ad on his hand for his
daughter anna dewitt but while he may know her
as anna we know her by a different name because
we know someone else whose pinky is gone elizabeth
she is booker's daughter let me dial things back a
bit and talk about comstock because then this
will tie things together should booker accept
the baptism he would then become comstock he
would then eventually meet rosalind and create
columbia during this time as leader and as prophet
he gained a very large following of devotees one
of whom was called annabelle the alternate version
of annabelle dewitt but now annabelle comstock or
as we know her lady comstock but we know the pair
couldn't have a kid due to comstock being sterile
thanks to those tear tests so he sought out an
heir and the three of them comstock rosalind and
robert determined that an heir from another
world could work this is what caused robert
to meet with booker take anna then jump back into
their world the only question is what is what the
luteces is trying to help us and encourage booker to
find elizabeth well the pair ended up discovering
what we did that the destruction of new york would
happen if things went to plan so they attempted
to fix their mistake but as we talked about
earlier they were killed before they could try
however for some reason they were able to move
across space and time whenever and wherever
they wanted allowing them both to exist and not
exist remember it's all a matter of perspective
seeing as they were still technically alive they
continued with their plan and found booker they
then took booker from his world into one where
comstock was in hopes of redoing their mistake
but it didn't work if the coin flip is to be taken
literally then this isn't the first time they've
tried to get booker to kill comstock and if i'm
not mistaken then we are the 123rd attempt at
this experiment this would explain why rosalind
in the intro was very annoyed at the experiments
as they keep failing elizabeth had learned all
of this and both booker and her agreed that the
only way to prevent comstock from ever doing all
of this was to smother him in his crib when he
was a baby booker meant this literally elizabeth
meant this metaphorically technically comstock's
first day on earth was after the baptism so by
killing booker before the baptism takes place
she would end up killing comstock before he was
even born the only reason this works is because
the baptism is the constant the outcome is the
variable but by killing him before the baptism
we change the constant and thus change the entire
timeline since booker was never given a choice at
the baptism the variables couldn't exist thus
removing all the comstocks and columbia's from
the timeline it's a bit confusing but i've always
understood this ending as all the bookers that
would accept the baptism meaning they would become
comstock would all die and those who don't accept
the baptism don't die since they never become
comstock you may notice during the scene that
none of them are wearing the necklace we gave
her meaning that our elizabeth is still alive
basically our elizabeth the one we've been with
since the beginning of the game is kind of like
the luteses whereas the letessas received their
trans-dimensional powers after death elizabeth
seems to just have them because she can open and
create tears after this bombshell of information
we get an after credits cutscene that shows
booker waking up to anna crying it's unclear how
to interpret this but some have claimed that this
is simply just another booker before he sold anna
or that because the timelines got reset so
to speak that everything is back to normal
but then there's been even more discussion about
whether or not anna is even truly in the crib
because we never see her personally i think they
just added this because they wanted the game to
have a mysterious cliffhanger as it's really hard
to care about when there isn't any substance to
go off of but it's not a huge problem since the
answer doesn't matter anyway this though is the
full and transparent story of bioshock infinite
what an absolute wild story this has become
so firstly i didn't mind the homage they paid
to rapture although it does feel a bit like
nostalgia bait more than anything to remind us
that we're still playing a bioshock game it was
cool but it felt a little forced however the
ending overall was fantastic admittedly it's
very confusing and definitely something i didn't
understand but as time went on things started to
click more and more there is a growing debate
though amongst the community about this ending
it's probably the only bioshock game that is as
heavily split some saying that this is the best
in the series and claiming that if you don't like
it it's because you don't understand it but some
argue back and say that they do understand it
and still dislike it or that this complexity is
reason enough for them to dislike it as for me
though i think this ending is really good would
have I preferred infinite not go as far as it
did with its sci-fi elements absolutely i think
the introduction of tears multiple universes and
quantum mechanics was a bit unnecessary as this
made the story a bit of a chore to sift through
so i could finally understand the meaning behind
everything but despite that infinite story wraps
up quite nicely and as a whole it's pretty great
once again infinite manages to completely fool
the player despite the expected plot twist and
the relationship between booker and elizabeth was
easily the best part of the game it also seemed to
do exactly what it set out to do provide the fans
a bioshock game that doesn't have many callbacks
to the other games allowing it to live on its
own that's what i would have said if they didn't
release the dlc bioshock infinite would eventually
add a two-part episodic dlc called burial at sea
and when i heard that the dlc was heading back
to our favorite underwater city i was all ears
Burial At Sea starts with elizabeth entering a
detective's office this detective is booker dewitt
it's a different booker but the same elizabeth we
can piece this together for multiple conversations
between the two the reason elizabeth shows up
here is because she's hiring this booker to find
a missing girl named sally considering how strong
elizabeth is thanks to her powers and how much
knowledge she has from those powers we can assume
that there's an underlying meaning to all of this
after accepting the job booker leaves the office
and we're finally able to see rapture in its
prime and it's magnificent i spent a good
hour in this area just taking everything in
even if it was something that was pretty much
insignificant it was still great to explore
we also get to see the little sisters up close
and this brings up something we should mention
the time and date for this dlc is december 31 1958
the same day that rapture would be under siege
by fontaine and his splicer army this obviously
caused a lot of tension within me while playing as
i knew at some point things were about to go off
furthermore that means that the little sisters at
this point were only bonded with one big daddy
because this is the same date that delta and
eleanor were patrolling the hallways of rapture so
elizabeth takes us to sander cohen as she believes
that cohen knows where sally went once again
i really like seeing sander cohen again and it
also further confirms that he was always a crazed
lunatic even before the riots on new year's eve
to get any information out of him we need to
dance for him just like his previous subjects
however just like that previous couple we upset
him and fitzpatrick shocks us by the way if that
name rings a bell here's a quick refresher
oh god you sick [__] let me out of there
afterwards booker and elizabeth wake up in a
bathysphere that is headed towards the fontaine
department store however we only get to explore
the warehouse section of it this department store
was sunk by andrew ryan during his feud with
fontaine he would eventually lock up any other
insane splicers down here so that rapture could
run smoothly this seems to operate like persephone
which was also a prison in rapture so i guess
this means persephone was for regular inmates and
people ryan believed were going to ruin his
city while the department stores seem to only
be related to fontaine and his army it's a little
weird but i'll go with it after tons of combat and
exploration we get some backstory on sally and
discover that after fontaine and the orphanage
went down lots of the little girls were roaming
the city sally came by and booker being nice opted
to give her a place to settle down but he assumed
it would only be temporary she enjoyed being
around booker quite a lot and ended up staying
permanently however this booker like the others
was also a gambler and an alcoholic one day he
was gambling and without noticing sally was taken
booker was then told shortly after that she was
confirmed dead but as we'll discover soon that
was a lie booker and elizabeth come across
sally meaning she's still in fact alive but
she's also inside of one of the little sister
vents and won't come out elizabeth has the
insane idea to heat up the vents and lock all the
entrances so that she only has one way to come out
after doing this booker runs to the event to
discover that she has become a little sister
clearly she is scared and agitated so that alerts
her big daddy and were forced to fight it also i
think this is a plot hole this should be an alpha
series big daddy not the bouncer type we see here
the bouncer and rosie big daddies of bioshock 1
existed at this point in time but were only used
for maintenance and underwater excavations the
alpha series were the only ones with a bond and
that bond was with one little sister after killing
the big daddy though we uncover the full truth of
episode 1, this booker is actually a comstock this
comstock however is unique to all the others as
instead of successfully taking anna from booker
he failed not only did booker have more control
of anna but their struggle left anna's head on
comstock's side decapitating her overcome with
guilt comstock asked the luteces to send him to
a place so that he may forget all he has done
this is what caused him to go to rapture and
re-adopt his booker name comstock is rightfully
shocked by this discovery and tries to apologize
but elizabeth isn't here for apologies and has him
killed by a big daddy, episode 1 minus the slight
mix-up with the big daddies was great and once
again makes sense elizabeth at the end of the game
wanted revenge for what comstock did to her we can
see that when booker attempts to stop her booker
of course clarifies that he wants to kill him for
her but this leaves a hole within her she won't be
allowed to take her anger out on the man who not
only imprisoned her but all the other elizabeths
that are connected to her she feels all their pain
which makes her want for revenge even greater
plus she also had to drown her own father so
not only could she not enact a revenge she had to
lose booker despite getting what she wanted which
was to eliminate comstock nothing felt complete so
when she discovered this comstock she decided to
torture him until she was satisfied obviously this
sort of ruins the ending of the main game since
this was supposed to eliminate all the comstocks
but i think the reason this occurred was because
since comstock left the columbia reality and
entered the rapture reality he was out of
bounds of the purge as i said though really great
episode but now things are going to start to dip
episode 2 starts with elizabeth in paris or at
least her version of paris we can tell because of
how dramatic everything is all the residents greet
her and treat her like royalty at times everyone's
also singing along together and there's even
a bird that sings as well when it lands on her
finger everything is absolutely exaggerated but
it's all taken away when sally arrives elizabeth
wakes up and not only is there a ghost version of
booker here but atlas shows up atlas decides to
shoot elizabeth but is stopped once she tells him
that she can get him back to rapture with the help
of dr su chong atlas is also now using sally as a
bargaining chip to get elizabeth to do his bidding
i'm starting to get flashbacks one thing i sort
of glossed over was booker as a ghost what seems
to be a figment of her imagination something she
made up she clearly cares about booker that is
her father after all so she's probably still
trying to deal with the guilt of killing him
back in the main game but we aren't done with the
bizarre twists as we find elizabeth's dead body
furthermore due to this she isn't able to see the
different realities and the tears in the doors
like she used to she's just a normal human girl
without any way to leave rapture when she's done
the luteces has warned that if she went to
rapture to enact revenge on this comstock
she would collapse so to speak i think collapse
in this context is the other elizabeth's merging
with her removing her powers and becoming a normal
human again i don't think it's explained why she
loses her powers but it's possible that entering
the different reality changed her powers a bit
but that's just speculation more importantly
though i have to ask how did she die this is
confirmed to be the same elizabeth from the main
game the same one who trapped songbird and rapture
immediately after getting her powers back but she
was somehow stopped by a big daddy it's possible
that she isn't on the same power level anymore due
to her being in a different reality as we can see
her struggling to open a very tiny tear early
in the episode so maybe what i say is true or
maybe i'm just making creative excuses for the
devs to get away with this either way elizabeth's
new objective is to rescue sally she feels guilt
over using her as bait and hurting her to torture
comstock she realizes that just as comstock used
her to get what he wants she used sally to get
what she wanted making her know better than the
man she despised she wants to make things right
and make sure sally has a future and to do this
she needs to work with atlas and this is where
i started to lose interest infinite tried
so hard to separate itself from the other
game and it succeeded whether or not you agree
with this decision is up to you but you can't
deny that it's its own experience so why are we
going back and using story from the first game
it seems like the studio just couldn't get away
from their pride and joy that is bioshock 1
and needed to come up with a story to sell the
dlc firstly elizabeth needs to find suchong
and while she doesn't find him she does find his
temporary lab in here is photos of columbia as
well as a terror it's explained that the terror
elizabeth used to get to rapture took her here so
suchong with the assistance of andrew ryan moved
his equipment here to study the terror eventually
he would come in contact with jeremiah fink and
the two would collaborate and steal each other's
ideas this led to the creation of the vigors
and songbird it also led to the creation of the
big daddies but only partially as suchong was
still trying to figure out how a songbird bonded
with elizabeth as this was the critical piece he
was missing when it came to the big daddies with
this discovery elizabeth realizes that she can use
the tear to get into colombia and grab the lutest
particle so that she can make the department store
flow just like colombia floats sadly though the
device was destroyed so she needs to repair it
once it's fixed we can take the tear to colombia
you may be confused as to how a columbia like this
exists and honestly so am i it seems like the main
game really tied things up so by adding a new
colombia it sort of invalidates all that progress
even if this is just a terror to the past it's
still a columbia this shouldn't really be here
furthermore we also see a behind-the-scenes
conversation between the luteces and daisy
we learned that the luteces were behind the
actions of daisy back in finkton explaining
that daisy will die and that she needs to play her
part in order for elizabeth to become a woman and
once again i'm left confused daisy has spent years
under the oppression of columbia and its residents
she's also been a leader of the vox for presumably
a few years as well and she's willing to throw all
this away because the luteces tell her what to
do but i remind you that the lutes has worked
for father comstock the person she's trying to
kill so how can she even trust them furthermore
if the lutes has even managed to convince her by
showing her other realities or by predicting the
future then this ruins part of the main game's
story as booker could have easily just told her
that he was from a different timeline and not an
imposter which could have stopped all the people
we killed that were a part of the box it's never
explained what ultimately convinced her so the
team is once again able to get away with this
vague scene changing the story by giving away
very little information that a was never hinted at
and b should have never even happened is not good
storytelling and also in an effort to clown
this scene again because i think it's funny
all they said was to take the boy hostage nothing
about the blood wiping so once again i have to ask
what the point was eventually elizabeth will grab
the blue test particle but suchong won't let her
leave until she gets him hair of the test subject
that was bonded to songbird which is quite funny
as he is literally talking to that test subject
the hair sample is located in fink's office and
is a really nice location as we get to see all
the tests that he ran trying to get songbird to
connect with elizabeth it's also pretty horrifying
the depths he was willing to go to to do something
like this like hooking up an animal to a mask that
would constantly pump oxytocin into their lungs
as well as the other failed test subjects still
in the laboratory elizabeth then grabs the hair
sample and delivers it to suchong via pneumo tube
and i don't think it's ever explained in this
game but shouldn't the numo tubes be connected i
can't imagine that the two packages the item and
floats it across the water so how does this get
from point a to point b when fontaine died ryan
forced suchong to work for him and that's why his
new lab was at the artemis suites far away from
this department store plus the store is thousands
of meters below rapture since ryan sunken
so is the pneumo tube still connected to the other
tube or was there never a tube in the first place
it's not a huge concern just something i noticed
after delivering the hair ryan appears on the
intercom and attempts to kill us we escape his
thugs make it to the desired location use the lutece
test particle to float the department store back
up to rapture and then get knocked out by atlas's
men after this the story goes back to the roots of
bioshock 1 as atlas wants us to look for the ace
in the hole who of course is jack and while i was
very excited to see jack in some fashion i don't
even really think this was necessary in the over
10 years since i played the first bioshock game
not once did i wonder how atlas got jack i think
it's more important that he got jacket all more
than how he got him there's also a myriad of
ways you could have explained that he got him
to rapture this is going to be a bit bold of me
but i'd like to rewrite this episode in a way
that would make more sense at least to me firstly
remove any mention of atlas up until this point
allow elizabeth to get up and question how she is
alive along with booker it'll draw more attention
to how elizabeth ended episode 1 standing and is
now starting this episode on the ground maybe even
add some blood as well to show that she didn't
pass out but was actually injured with atlas
in the picture all i could care about was him i
didn't even bother questioning how booker even got
here the way booker's written into this episode
is totally fine i'm actually okay with him just
being a figment of her imagination the rest of the
episode should be spent trying to find sally and
then this would be a good time to have sally also
be held by suchong since it'll force elizabeth
to go to colombia and get her hair in exchange
for sally this however though does involve the
lutece particle and columbia something i'd prefer
to avoid in this episode so maybe we can have some
joke scene where elizabeth reveals to suchong
that she is in fact the test subject and then
maybe have suchong freak out and get a little
angry at the fact the solution to his issue was
literally right in front of him and seeing as he's
in rapture and not the department store this could
make suchong be the sole reason the sword was
lifted as he needs her hair this not only connects
the following scene with andrew ryan where he says
that the deal between suchong and elizabeth was
not one he was authorized to make but this also
fits narratively with suchong as a character who
not only worked with fontaine before he died and
could maybe discover the real identity of atlas
but also show that he is still a person willing
to do anything to get what he wants once elizabeth
makes it to suchong she can then drop off her
hair and then right when she meets sally she gets
knocked out by some thugs which leads to the scene
right here once this starts have the bag stay on
elizabeth's head but have atlas talk to his crew
while we're here it sets up atlas but also lets
the veteran players get excited as his accent
is very recognizable they could even change the
name to man instead of atlas in the subtitles
momentarily so that the reveal isn't spoiled
then when the hype of his appearance is still
high rip the bag off and show him even keeping
this part where the light blocks his face but then
reveals him as he steps closer would have also
worked as well personally i would have preferred
this dlc just continue its own story and have
atlas be revealed in the last few moments since
atlas is now a main character in this episode
from the start it takes all focus off everyone
else as he's easily the most important character
in this episode doing this would also remove
the questionable decisions that elizabeth makes
throughout this dlc as from the moment she meets
with him she knows that she'll betray him and it
ruins all the build up when it's not only hammered
in multiple times that atlas will likely betray
her but also the fact that elizabeth keeps helping
him despite knowing she won't get the upper hand
on him as we discover at the end the reason she's
doing this is because within all the doors there
was a timeline that shows sally having a future
thanks to jack rescuing her but to do this she
needs to go along with the events of the story
in order to make this all happen which not only
undermines all the power and skill atlas has as a
leader but also makes the reveal of how atlas got
his hands on jack just really awkward furthermore
the only reason she was able to do any of this was
because of booker who reminds her that she used to
see all the doors meaning she has all the memories
of all the doors regardless of whether it was
the past present or future so booker tries to
get her to remember where the location of the
ace and the hole is this confirmed a suspicion
i had and that was that booker was placed in this
episode strictly to explain plots and discoveries
the writers couldn't explain on their own and this
makes everything feel so forced just have booker's
stay a memory her memory of booker the booker
who she grew to love and appreciate and have him
be the shoulder she can cry on they are father
and daughter after all don't add this current
booker that is helping discover the next step in
the story because elizabeth can't remember or is
incapable of making a decision it just feels like
such a waste to have the story the way it is now
and it goes back to what i said earlier as it
answers a question we didn't even really need
answered the best thing to come from this part
though was the interrogation scene which makes
me extremely uncomfortable where's me ace in the
hole i don't know what else rests in the lobe
creativity individuality personality in
short what makes you you, continuing with
the story though elizabeth needs to get to suchong's clinic in order to find info on jack
she then finds the paper that has the would you
kindly passphrase and then gives it to atlas
during this level we do get to see how suchong
died rather than hearing it and while cool the
story is doing that thing again where it's
trying to fit elizabeth into the plot by
having her be the sole reason behind all these
events she was the reason that the big daddies
could bond to any little sister she was then
responsible for suchong's death and is of course
responsible for the events of the whole series
since she gave atlas the passphrase for jack
it's completely unnecessary to do all of this
and i have no idea why they thought this was a
good idea also unless i'm mistaken i'm pretty sure
the bonding process was created using pheromones
of the big daddies combined with the mental
conditioning that the little sisters underwent
we use the pheromones ourselves in bioshock 1
and we get to see the little sisters minds in
bioshock too so this whole scene is confusing
as it implies that just a little bit of atom
was all that was needed even though it's known
that the big daddies were spliced beyond belief
to even get them to function in the suit so
they already have adam in them plus the adam
the little sisters have is probably recycled
you could claim that the little sisters have
unique atoms since their bodies do contain the sea
slug that produces it but we can see them drinking
adam on occasion in game thus it's recycled
anyway so this is just confusing for no reason
elizabeth has such a vital role in her own reality
but they needed to make her have the same role in
the rapture reality but it was just unnecessary
now instead of saying that the addiction of
adam the feud between fontaine and ryan and
the values of rapture were all contributing
factors to not only the downfall of rapture but
the events of the game it can now just be boiled
down to elizabeth did it to help sally it ruins
years of work and that is extremely upsetting
after elizabeth gets the passphrase she gives it
to atlas as she has to sensibly to sally being
rescued to which she receives a wrench to the
head for her assistance we then get a slideshow
of the events that took place in bioshock 1
and see that her vision became a reality as
sally is rescued by jack and given a future as she
comes back to reality we can see her holding sally
while elizabeth eventually succumbs to her wounds
and dies thus ending the dlc burial at sea wasn't
terrible but it definitely wasn't great either
it's a dlc that probably didn't need to exist but
i would have accepted its existence if it didn't
fumble so hard in the second episode the dlc not
only has a few retcons and plot holes but also
undermines all the story and world building the
original game set out to create by pinning all the
events on one character a character that shouldn't
have even had this vital of a role in the first
place and arguably shouldn't have even been here
anyway infinite was made to be different and a
separation from the series and while i didn't
appreciate it that much as i've said before i
will at least commend them for sticking to their
original vision and trying to create something
new despite that they still couldn't get away from
rapture and thus needed to go back was it great to
see rapture in its prime as well as the original
cast of characters absolutely but the rest of
the dlc soured any enjoyment that i had from it
bioshock infinite as a whole is a surreal
experience it's got a compelling story with
a wonderful twist and a great dynamic between
the two main characters and even a decent setup
to a dlc in episode 1 culminating in a good game
but it also has a lack of interesting audio logs
bland gameplay repetitive locations and an abysmal
second episode that ruins the great parts infinite
established tearing it down in the process head
infinite just ended at the main game i would have
called it great or even fantastic but burial at
sea went too far it said that the series had ended
on such a conflicting note like this where people
are more than likely to argue whether or not the
game was even good to begin with rather than just
appreciating how far the series has come infinite
leaves a permanent stain on this series fantastic
legacy and that's truly what upsets me the most
despite bioshock infinite being the final game
in the series we still have more bioshock to talk
about as throughout the game's lifecycle two books
were written bioshock rapture and bioshock mind
in revolt now both of these books are not comics
so this won't be the most visually entertaining
section but i will try to provide footage of the
characters and locations mentioned so if a book
happens to mention finkton for example then i'll
put some finkton gameplay on screen as well as
any characters that are mentioned as well also
because of some possible copyright concerns i
won't be talking about every detail and thus
will only be summarizing the important parts
hopefully though it will be enough to get you
a general understanding of the material so that
you can come to a decision on whether or not you
should read it yourself so firstly let's get the
easy one out of the way bioshock mind in revolt
is a 30 page ebook written by joe fielder mind
in revolt was actually written in house as joel
fielder was one of the writers for the game so
this story is separated into different parts as
the different chapters are various interviews
with daisy fitzroy which are being conducted by dr
francis pinchot these chapters aren't published in
a professional manner as they're just notes and
transcripts and we can see from the forward and
afterward of the book that the person putting all
these together is a doctor pettifog the reason he
has decided to publish these interviews is that
he believes this will lead to a better columbia
however dr pettifog is rightfully worried about
the outcome of this publication as dr francis was
meeting with the city's most notorious criminal
and from what we'll see in the notes he is
indifferent about her as he cares more about her
mind rather than her actions so some people may
see him as a traitor and refuse to see the results
of his work all of these interviews occurred over
six days as our first transcript is may 7 1909 and
our last is may 13 1909. that means the events of
bioshock infinite have yet to occur as that was
in 1912. the first question though is how did dr
francis meet with daisy well according to the
first transcript daisy fitzroy was captured by
some authorities down in finton after hearing this
news he immediately gathered all the paperwork
necessary that would allow him to interview
her dr francis believes that while the people
of colombia are objectively better than the people
down below referring to those in the united states
he thinks much can be learned from these lesser
people he wants to see what makes these people
tick and hopes that discovering this information
could lead to treatment his logic is definitely
there but it's a bit flawed as it seems like
he wants to see why people who don't conform
to columbia's ideals are the way that they are
in hopes of treating them to see the beauty that
columbia provides it's not perfect but in terms of
therapy he's kind of on the right track before the
interview begins dr francis reads off a list of
her crimes which were included but not limited to
murder transportation of firearms manufacturing
of explosive devices and the printing of material
that promoted unionization public assembly and the
general undermining of the columbian government
that last crime refers to her manifesto called
the people's voice which is a book we can find
in game although we aren't actually allowed to
read it even though we already know this mind in
revolt does confirm that all of this started after
the death of lady comstock as we know that father
comstock killed her and then blamed it on daisy as
you would expect she is very uncooperative in this
interview so dr francis takes the opportunity
to read some of the quotes in the manifesto
eventually daisy will speak out and the two will
get into an argument as daisy sees dr francis like
everyone else in columbia as she says when it
comes down to it one snake is the same as any
other dr francis attempts to reassure her that
he merely just wants to understand her and not
harm her so the following day he lets daisy ask
the first question the two would then discuss how
each arrived in colombia and we learned that daisy
along with many other black mexican irish chinese
and jewish people were just brought in during the
dead of night many were either convinced to come
aboard due to columbia waving their past crimes
some needed money to feed their families and
others were just taken from their homes dr francis
is quite shocked at the revelation to hear that
fink would knowingly employ criminals and finds
it absurd this interview would be the first of
many times dr francis would hear about the truth
of colombia and will eventually get to see how
this affects him later on after days of interviews
dr france's supervisor is becoming quite unhappy
regarding his results and suggests that a change
in strategy be implemented he suggests that they
conduct a phranology test which was ultimately
discredited years later and has been the cause
of many racist and sexist claims such as certain
races being inferior to others due to the shape of
their brain and that women's brains have larger
sections for child care and religion while they
had smaller sections for arts and sciences his
supervisor also recommends a new study that
they're conducting which would eventually be
called lobotomy neither of these are something
dr francis wants as he claims that his style is
vital to colombia's growth more interviews will
continue and we can see dr francis getting more
and more annoyed at her calling her responses
blasphemous eventually daisy will make a remark
towards the doctor which causes him to slap her
she laughs a bit after this encounter as she's
finally able to see the real doctor as she claims
wednesday may 12th a few days before daisy will be
put under the supervisor's orders and forced to be
lobotomized was where the shortest interview took
place as dr francis is reading back the results
of her iq test and discovered that daisy scored a
149 which not only according to the scoring means
she is a genius in the eyes of columbia but is
also higher than dr francis himself who scored a
146 after seeing these results though he will end
the interview to think about how to proceed next
clearly he is running out of time and his
supervisor is getting very annoyed at his
lack of progress in his private journal we can
read a transcript between the two of them that
occurred once he shut the voxaphone off overall
i don't mind how this was handled but it did seem
a bit fast as one day there is no progress
then the next day she spills her entire plan
this is also the reason why writing in this format
can be very restrictive as it's meant to mimic a
compilation of journal and recording entries so
we obviously won't hear any of this since this was
discussed after the recording was turned off it
makes sense in regards to the format of the story
it just feels a bit out of nowhere and caused a
bit of whiplash while reading as for her plans
though she spoke about a plot to break her out
of jail and that if dr francis is involved in her
escape it will end in little to no bloodshed this
actually changes dr francis's thoughts regarding
his work as while he is an upstanding citizen of
colombia doubts have started to creep into his
mind this made him realize that sin exists in all
men regardless of their place in life as while he
thinks very highly of himself and is void of
such rebellious ideas to discover that these
thoughts were in his mind was a bit shattering to
him he attempted to quell these thoughts within
him but realized intense transformation would be
required to do so such as changing the current
comstock center from a research facility to a
re-education center but the thought of torturing
these patients with auditory and visual stimuli
that would ultimately force them to conform to
the proper ideals of columbia is terrifying
and something he once again wants to avoid
the final day approaches and during their final
interview we can see that daisy has the upper hand
she's the one controlling the interview while dr
francis is still consumed by the thoughts of what
he believes is right for colombia but also what is
right for himself eventually a break-in occurs and
dr francis decides that he will end up helping
daisy and gives her a set of keys that will not
only unlock some of the facilities doors but
also her cell she meets up with some of her men
and thanks the doctor for helping her escape but
before leaving gives him a pardon gift which is
a bullet through his head her final line before
killing dr francis is it ain't a matter of have
to it's a matter of want it seems that despite
how honest dr francis was with his intentions
regarding their interview daisy refused to
believe him and only saw him as a pawn in her game
honestly this was quite a sad story as dr francis
albeit still stuck in his ways was at least
willing to learn from daisy which is something
not many people in colombia would even try to do
to end the publication we have an afterword from
dr pettifog who explains that despite dr francis's
interest in daisy the blame is not entirely his
own as the betrayal of the mind can happen to
anyone even the great citizens of columbia and it
was thanks to his bravery and research that they
were able to come up with an array of treatment
methods which will be hosted at the all-new
comstock re-education center dr francis's worst
thoughts had come to life the facility turned
towards more forceful methods of change and we
can see this in game as the comstock house level
is the re-education center we could see the
numerous slideshows of phrenology and lobotomy as
well as the results they had on the patients it's
a truly horrific site mind revolt was a short but
sweet story it's not a necessary read as it only
discussed one instance than the colombian timeline
that ultimately wasn't too important but for
three dollars on amazon it was definitely worth
the price so if you're interested in a bit of the
thoughts on daisy fitzroy then i recommend you
pick this up our final book is bioshock rapture
an over 400 page novel that details some of the
events prior to the first bioshock game as opposed
to the previous book that was written in-house
this was written by a third-party author named
john shirley however the project was overseen
by game director ken levine and according to some
tweets and interviews regarding the book he also
got to write the epilogue and prologue while jon
surely handled the rest to some of you that name
may sound familiar as while he does produce some
books of his own he was also contracted to write
many books for other games such as halo watchdogs
and borderlands so before things begin we can read
a prologue that takes place before raptor's
creation and it gives us a look into why it
was created the two characters in the prologue are
andrew ryan and sullivan, sullivan was a security
officer for ryan which is how the two met he came
into ryan's office to give him the reports he
asked for and was displeased with both of them one
was about the ongoing union strikes and how many
companies workers were fighting for better rights
ryan believes these workers to be soviet agents
as russia was going under similar strikes at the
same time he finds it absurd that they want better
wages in working conditions as he claims that
this is the basis of socialism something ryan is
definitely not fond of the final report was the
nail in the coffin for ryan he received reports
of what occurred in japan during world war ii the
report not only had pictures of the bombings with
the effects they had on some of the citizens that
survived he realized that the world was spiraling
into chaos and with nuclear weapons being created
an all-out atomic war would be inevitable so ryan
set his plans in motion he plans to make a place
untouched by the government where people live away
from rules and regulations we of course know this
to be rapture before the prologue ends we get a
backstory of ryan's escape from russia we also get
to learn his full name which i don't recall ever
being stated in the games before but it is Andrei
Rianofski his backstory goes into grave detail
about the world that andrew ryan saw with his
eyes saying things like the dawn sky the colors
of a deep bruise and the cutting winds serrated
by sleet the problem with books is the lack of
a visual which is why they tend to go into detail
about the surroundings to give the reader an idea
of what to imagine and i'm glad this style wasn't
lost when making this book however there is a
minor inconsistency as the book states he fled
russia in 1918 when in fact in game it was 1919
not a huge deal but something i just wanted to
mention part one of the book covers chapters
one through five and it's all about the building
of rapture we also get to meet our protagonist
bill mcdonough bill was contracted to help fix
something at the building that ryan owned which
is how the two met we also learned that the
reason andrew ryan is so rich is that he owns
a significant amount of oil and coal on top of
owning the second biggest railroad in the country
details like this occur throughout the whole book
and it's definitely something i took a liking to
at the end of the day it's not important how ryan
got his money just that he had the money to build
rapture but the book wanted to add these details
to piece together the small holes left by the game
it's the details that'll make you say oh so that's
how that happened or that's why this occurred and
the book manages to excel at this something
else i noticed was the use of audio logs from
the games as on page 30 bill is currently fixing
ryan's toilet and when ryan sees his work he asks
about the type of fitting claiming that the other
guys are using tin while bill is using brass this
is taken directly from an audio log in game wait
says it what's with all the brass fittings general
contractor had me down for the tin well i says i
suppose it's the contractor then he'll be bailing
out your loo once a fortnight is it if it's price
you're worried about i'll be picking up the brass
so not to worry this small inclusion made me feel
a lot more comfortable when reading as the story
and its additional material were taken into
consideration it sounds like the bare minimum
when it comes to writing a book for a game but
i appreciated it nonetheless the rest of the
part switches between bill mcdonagh and a frank
gorlund frank gorland is a simple bartender that
likes to fudge games of boxing to make a quick
buck and also likes to use the bar as a way to
gain information some of this information he
received was on the project that andrew ryan
was working on and he figured that if he could
get involved in this project he could take it
from under his nose if that sounds like someone
specific then you would be right as by the end
of the part we discover that frank gorland
is actually frank fontaine his chapters were
excellent as they showed the lengths he's willing
to go to get what he wants and also displayed his
skill at creating different identities and
personalities as he switches quite a lot
throughout the park by the end of part one
he is close to finding out ryan's plan but
he hasn't found out where the project is as for
bill mcdonagh he's made quite the impression
on injurine and has been promoted to the lead
contractor for the building of rapture ryan took
bill on a trip to visit some of his friends these
friends of course being jasmine jolene and sander
cohen, sander cohen was used in this part as a way
for ryan to show bill how some of these people are
constrained by the world and hopes to create a
society that doesn't need to worry about these
constraints eventually ryan and bill will leave
and take a trip to iceland to which a boat will
be waiting to take them to the building site of
rapture ryan also shows bill a small model of
the city and what he plans to have it look like he
also explains how arcadia works which is something
i did not expect to read as according to ryan
arcadia has a system that brings in reflected
sunlight as well as electrical light then this
will be used by the trees which will eventually
lead to them producing oxygen once again a detail
that ties in some of the questions left untouched
by the game the final pages of the part are bill
ryan and many of the other contractors staring
at awe at the foundation of rapture knowing that
in time a new wonder of the world will be created
part 2 is chapters 6 through 15 and this chapter
tends to skip around a bit as we get to see many
different characters take center stage for a bit
all while jumping around in the timeline as we go
from 1949 to 1953 within just a couple dozen pages
these chapters are here to add more substance to
the story by giving context to future events
providing more backstory on the game via audio
logs or just small conversations that flesh out
the world for example there's a more detailed look
at julie langford's audio log where she's upset
that ryan's turning her arcadia guarded into a
paid attraction but then a few pages later there's
a quick scene between sofia lamb and a patient
furs that gets interrupted momentarily when
eleanor comes into the room since this part
spans many years in the rapture timeline lots
of progress has been made and many people are
flocking to the underwater city in hopes of
striking it big we also get to see lots of the
games cast in this part as many of the main and
side characters from both games are given center
stage think of it as an anthology of sorts as every
few pages the story pivots to another scene and
since they're so far apart from one another
most of the short stories don't contradict
or overlap i really liked being able to see all
the characters in these new situations as they
all have these unique reactions to everything
going on not just in rapture but in the moment
like this one part where tenenbaum and suchong
are trying to perform a pregnancy examination
and it's hilarious hearing them talk about this
child like it's a test subject and conversating
about their experiences in examinating children
a while completely ignoring the fact that this
woman they're testing on is crying out in
extreme pain but while most of this part
is broken up into small stories there is some
important developments happening within them as
we start to see the beginning of sofia lamb and
her family via the free therapy sessions as well
as the discovery and creation of adam we also get
to read about some of the more depressing events
that transpire in rapture like all the people who
feel trapped and alone as they can't leave rapture
due to ryan's orders or how someone screwed over
another man's business which eventually led to a
dispute and a shootout i like that this book was
able to convey to the reader that rapture wasn't
a complete utopia we already knew this from the
games but we only understood that things became
problematic after rapture was up and running
but things are going wrong and it's not even
finished yet towards the end of the part is where
we get to the real meat of the story as splicers
are introduced fontaine and ryan are attempting
to take each other down and people are irritated
about the living conditions things haven't fully
gone to [__] yet as the bombing in 1958 is still
a couple years away but it's very clear that
rapture is starting to crack the book is slowly
but truly giving us all the different events of
rapture that would eventually lead to its downfall
part 2 is by far the longest part taking up around
half the book and is by far my favorite part as
there is tons of references to past locations and
characters that allow us to take what we already
know about them and apply to these pages i found
myself remembering all their backstories when all
the characters appeared and tried to take that
into consideration when they were relevant to
the scene while this part was initially all over
the place and sometimes a bit hard to organize
when taking into account the full timeline it
ultimately doesn't matter as once again most
of these stories aren't relevant to one another
and are spread far apart enough that they won't
contradict or overlap but as the part reached
the end it started injecting familiar material
that fans of the games would remember along with
a cohesive story that would set up the final part
part 3 is chapters 15-20 and is very similar to
the end of part 2 in the sense that there are
sporadic stories that may jump ahead a few months
or a year but they all connect on this very thin
timeline that make up the actual story this part
not only has a few pages dedicated to providing
background on events we already know of but also
allow us to see many events that were briefly
talked about in the games for example the raid
on fontaine futuristics that would eventually
lead to the fake death of fontaine and the
creation of atlas as well as the bombing on
new year's eve were all mentioned and we're not
only able to see the events happen but also the
aftermath of said events we were also able to
get an in-depth look on the conversation between
fontaine suchong and tenenbaum regarding the
mental conditioning of jack and how they were
going to steal ryan's child and even the doubts
that tenenbaum would have throughout the story
that would eventually lead to how we see her in
game as she has a change of heart about the little
sisters these were fantastic to read about and i
was so excited to see how all of this fit into the
story however not all of these events had the same
feeling there's a few inconsistencies in this part
as well we talked about one before regarding the
year ryan left russia but there's also a few more
in these later chapters the book never mentions
any discoveries of tares within rapture which we
know did exist at some point thanks to burial
at sea however this book was written in 2011 a
few years before burial at sea was even released
so i'm willing to overlook this simply because
the game was still in development however one i
won't forgive is jasmine's death as we know in
fort frolic sander cohen wants us to kill some of
his associates so we can display their picture on
his art project to kill one of them we need to go
into the room where jasmine was killed so that we
can get him to spawn in the bar behind us in this
room is jasmine's body along with a bloody weapon
implying she was beat to death we also hear some
of the conversation thanks to some of the ghostly
apparitions that occurred throughout the game
so it's clear that she was killed with a weapon
but according to the book ryan strangled her to
death now you could make the argument that he
strangled her then hit her with a blunt object
but the book never mentions anything about a
weapon so it leads me to believe that they had
incorrectly added this what bothers me the most
is that this is a required and integral part of
the story and was somehow missed despite this
being overlooked by game director ken levine as
well as all the other writers and designers that
shirley was in contact with i can see some small
detail being left out that was maybe mentioned
once in a random audio log but for something
such as this that is not only one of the most
important parts of bioshock's story but is also
required to watch if you want to complete the game
is baffling how this was incorrect as we go
through the final pages everything is turning
into the rapture we know from the games raids for
food are happening all the time ryan is losing
influence and the little sisters are patrolling
the hallways for adam at the end diane mcclintlock
who you'll remember from bioshock 1 as ryan's love
interest for a time and also the one who recorded
that bombing during new year's eve ends up joining
atlas and betraying ryan until she accidentally
discovers that atlas is fontaine and even though
she would have definitely kept his secret atlas
couldn't take the chance and stabs her letting
her bleed out on the floor this is just like the
other events we talked about before as this was
literally from an audio log in game but now we
get to see the full story behind it as for our
protagonist if we remember from an audio log in
the game we know that he was going to kill ryan
if he had to and when bill his wife eileen and
his daughter sophie attempt to escape rapture he
realizes what needs to be done he points his gun
at ryan but he couldn't do it ryan gave him this
job and allowed him to create his city and it's
because of his generosity that he couldn't pull
the trigger ryan takes the opportunity to fight
back smacking bill in the head with his cane and
while bill maintains the upper hand by bashing
him with his gun he once again couldn't finish the
job he wishes andrew ryan good luck and leaves his
office the family along with bill's friend roland
wallace make it to the bathyspheres and take it
all the way back up to the lighthouse but they're
caught by ryan's guards these guards are karlowski
redgrave and candavish names you won't be familiar
with but were quite frequent throughout the book
and are friends of bill everyone is arguing over
what to do as bill and his family want to leave
but the guards won't let him everyone is also
split in regards to bill's family as while the
order was just for roland and bill there was
nothing about his wife and child eventually
an argument would break out between the three
guards that left one dead redgrave and karlovsky
take bill and wallace back to rapture but allow
his wife and child to leave as for their fates
roland wallace became a test subject for sue
chong and was subjected to the enraged plasmid
which we can hear the results of from an audio log
in bioshock 1 and bill is executed for his crimes
we could see bill's body in game and it shows
that he was crucified but according to the book
since redgrave and karlovsky liked bill they opted
to kill him first as to not let him suffer even
though bill's capture was ryan's order andrew
ryan didn't come to the execution showing that
even though he was a traitor he was ultimately
losing a dear friend and couldn't see him die
i loved the relationship these two had throughout
the book as through bill's eyes were able to see
this different andrew ryan one that had a bit
more compassion and more drive the final pages are
about bill's family who are now on the surface his
daughter was diagnosed with agoraphobia thanks to
rapture and while a bit better off Eliane is still
suffering from everything that occurred the last
line is the two talking about how bill would have
loved to see the surface again bioshock rapture
was fantastic i've always been a visual learner
which is why i prefer manga over books like this
but i can't deny that for only ten dollars this
was a genuinely great read and that goes for mind
and revolt as well i highly recommend both books
if you have the time and money for them if you're
interested in a bit of the backstory regarding
daisy fitzroy then mind and revolt will be a
short but sweet read as for bioshock rapture i
think if you enjoy rapture even just a little bit
you will love this book the constant callbacks to
past events and characters as well as its ability
to fill in some of the gaps left by the story was
more than enough to give it my recommendation with
all the games and books discussed i could finally
say that we have reached the end of bioshock
despite the criticism that i gave i would
ultimately recommend everything discussed
in this video that goes for both the books and
games while some are better than others each one
has at least something that makes the game worth
playing whether that's the setting characters or
world building each game excels at something it
is without a doubt one of the best series ever
made and i can't thank you enough for allowing me
to talk about them one more time but even though
i said this was the end apparently it's not as
netflix has announced a bioshock movie and i
guess a fourth game is in production there is very
little information surrounding these additions to
the series but i will attempt to remain hopeful
video game movies and shows are either amazing
or terrible and while i'm always willing to give
it a try i'd be lying if i said i wasn't worried
i think a good setting for the movie would
definitely be pre-civil war rapture but that
would inevitably run into issues with the book
so continuity and canon discussion will probably
occur as for the game apparently on a podcast
called the sacred symbols the host claims that the
game will take place in a 1960 city in antarctica
called borealis admittedly that does sound quite
interesting but what's more worrying is the story
surrounding the game this is around the same time
as bioshock 1 and while it is far away from
rapture are they just going to move away from
it all together or will the team make reference to
it i feel like it could be possible if this could
work as long as they don't mention anyone from
the current trilogy it would suck but if they
start adding characters we're familiar with then
we'll have to take the other games into account
which will probably result in a really messy story
regardless if any of these projects are actually
released expect me to talk about them when they
do for the final time though thank you all for
joining me on this journey through the bioshock
series and i hope you enjoyed if you did be sure
to leave a like and subscribe if you're new we
have a ton more games i'd love to cover so if
this style of videos is interesting to you then i
hope you stick around for more as always thank you
to my returning viewers for coming back to another
video and with that take care everyone and goodbye